[Music]
um
[Laughter]
hey everybody please tell me that you
can hear us because we were having
problems with the
audio earlier like on this laptop i can
check please tell me yeah yeah okay so
it's fine and it sounds fine okay it's
normal it doesn't sound like it's all
right that's cool yeah that was the
weirdest [ __ ] that's why we're a
little late starting because it wasn't
the microphone it was the speakers on
the thing like i couldn't hear anything
and when i went in there to fix the
audio
it was like my speakers weren't there
like in the settings and then like it
wasn't letting me turn the volume up and
then obs crashed and i had to restart
blah blah so it was like this big
[ __ ]
issue
uh granthar says guns and roses playing
in daytona tomorrow let's all go
no
is it free even if it's free yeah it
wouldn't be free because i still have to
pay for gas to like drive over there
oscar says watch x i will i promise is
it cheaper to rent now
like i was kind of wait i want to see it
but i didn't want to like necessarily
pay 20 dollars because we didn't see it
when it was in the theater because we
missed it
and
it's streaming but i think for a while
it was 19.99 and i said well i want to
see it but because if i'd seen it at
theater i wouldn't have had to pay
because we have
uh you know amc stoves yeah we've got
pookie back there playing with the toys
whenever the show starts she's got to be
back there playing with the toys she's
like well i'm you know she thinks she's
on the show
i think you're on the show
now she's throwing she picked it up
through it we should have pookie cam
yeah
to put another camera down there
to see what pogie's doing
yeah i should if i could figure out how
to do that i might i might do that well
it's like not like i don't have like 40
000 things like already connected over
here but if i could figure out how to do
it yeah we need another camera angle
from over there see yeah because she
does funny [ __ ] back there all the time
yeah you just guys never see it and i
wish she could see it because she's back
there like rolling around with her big
old belly sticking out and like
she looks like a gummy bear when she's
on her back too because she's just this
big body with these little bitty short
feet
short legs look like little chicken
drumsticks
she's like the cat version of a wiener
dog
she's like a wiener dog she is kind of
yeah but they say that's her breed you
know this is the sheep like that yeah
she's a manx yeah and that's kind of
like they're supposedly like kind of
round with like little short limbs
like and her front limbs are a little
her front legs are a little bit shorter
than her back legs
but so it looks real funny when she like
walks around because she's got like this
this little pudgy round body and then
she's got like these little bitty short
legs so she's always like
tammy says pookie is the star she goes
don't you know that you are a red pookie
star
jenny wrote that song
one of my favorite things
with that strong one of my favorite
things is to come up with uh with songs
like classic rock songs that i can sing
to her but like change some of the words
to pookie-centric ways and like change
some of the stuff to her words
i think she likes it
when i sing to her good she doesn't hit
me or nothing people are still coming in
about half of the regulars are here
that's good we're at 13 we usually have
about 30
30 live regulars friday night yep seems
like the storm outside has passed holy
crap it was storming like so bad over
there it was so windy outside that it
was like blowing against my thought it
was a tornado for a second and i was
like oh [ __ ] we're dead but it wasn't
yeah it's really loud up here like when
it's windy yep
so um today we will talk about anything
you guys want to talk about
um any kind of unsolved mysteries or
paranormal if you have any questions or
you want to talk about any other cases
that we did or anything we did earlier
on this week you already had one one guy
come on about that show about that
australian dude saying that you got it
all wrong
see that one
oh yeah yeah but the thing about it is
that i got well i got the [ __ ] from like
three different sources yeah and the
main source that i used was i wanted to
make sure well i said well i want like
an australian source so that was kind of
the main one i used and then i used
wikipedia and a couple other ones yeah
but the thing about that is that and i
wanted to i said well i want an
australian source that is not
necessarily sympathetic to ned kelly so
you don't get a lot of the legend kind
of stuff yeah so
i don't know i don't pay that much
attention to he said he said it's all
legend that uh nobody liked him and he
was a criminal basically
basically what it was
well i kind of needed to say that we
said we basically said that well that's
what i'm saying so i kind of suspect
that
one maybe
yeah nobody likes a well actually
[ __ ] yeah uh two
i kind of feel
nobody likes that guy don't be that
person well actually don't don't do that
don't be that person i said you know
what i want a shirt that says that
nobody likes a well actually
[ __ ] [ __ ] i want one
that says that and i just want one that
says shut the [ __ ] up
but
those are my two dream shirts i think he
was a regular but he wanted you to go
back and actually [ __ ] lurk at some
sources and i'm thinking to myself jenny
doesn't have any [ __ ] time to go over
that case again she's on the next case
already
that's what i mean i've already gone
it's only coming god damn i had to like
yesterday i had to read like a whole
novel and then write a review of it and
record a review of it so i was just kind
of like look i don't have time for this
[ __ ] okay and the thing about the
show yeah it's show and i'm not really
all that worried about it was a long
time ago um i'd be more worried if it
was like a recent case that was like an
unsolved
murder or something like that yeah i'd
try to like get [ __ ] right but the thing
about ned kelly yeah he was a criminal
and everything like that but like i said
it was such a long time ago and
anything that happened that long time
ago is just going to be yes it's going
to be legend it's going to be muddled so
it's like i'm not really that worried
about it like billy the kid you know and
the thing about it too is i feel like
the person that commented that i don't
think they really listened to the whole
show because
i thought we were pretty even-handed on
the [ __ ] i mean i
thought like some of the incidents i was
like well this is what the cop said and
this is what the kelly said and they
said two completely different things and
we even kind of leaned into the fact
that we thought kelly made up a lot of
[ __ ] yeah so
like i said i don't like uh but okay a
lot of stuff over time gets lost
all right
they they pretty much know that john
wilkes booth
assassinated president abraham lincoln
but there are some people saying that
that body that they found wasn't john
wilkes booth
i wanted to do a show about that because
i was watching an old unsolved mysteries
and they went into that like because
somebody had a book out there where they
said oh that wasn't really john wilkes
booth it was some other dude and john
wilkes booth actually like lived a lot
longer than the guy yeah and then like
he confessed on his deathbed or whatever
and so i was like well i don't think
that's true necessarily but it might
make an interesting show well regardless
um some people think that
that the body that they pulled out of
that damn it was like a little tunnel
wasn't it or was it a no it's a barn is
it barn or no no again he crawled up
into something
and was killed and they pulled him out
anyway it doesn't matter
but then evidently some have said that
the body that they showed wasn't wasn't
booth that it must have been one of
booth's accomplices it wasn't he didn't
do it alone i don't believe he had a
team with him
yeah and uh it was one of the
accomplices probably and they just said
that that was booth to close the books
on the case and then they probably
secretly sent the pinkertons looking for
him and they never found him
see they when if you ever do some [ __ ]
like that they want to wrap it up quick
just look at the jfk shooting
they don't want the public [ __ ] going
hey you can kill a president get away
with it they want that [ __ ] solved
instantly
yeah and you know it makes them look
like they're on the ball right too right
you know
they don't like anything random or
anything
uh so no if you kill somebody then
they're gonna say they got you even if
they didn't yeah i mean the more high
profile it is the more likely it is that
they're just gonna and i'm not saying
that they're just gonna like
arrest any [ __ ] but
they might just like close the case like
wait for they're like well this is one
of the people and we'll just say this
person is the only person yeah you're
right so i kind of he was involved this
is the one that did it yeah and then
they go and then they might and some
guys keep looking for the keep looking
for that [ __ ] keep looking if
there are any more of them knowing that
if they find any more they'll kill those
guys too they'll never see the light of
day yeah just keep it on the deal
uh danny rowling says show about the
beast of jersey edward paisnell uh or
house goodcast that was the other one i
had that written down pen go can he feel
like throw me that pen and that piece of
paper i actually the um the beast of
jersey it's not in this week's poll but
i just made
i went back and i made
because i know that you guys like give
me good suggestions all the time and i
try to like write them all down and like
compile them but sometimes i lose the
[ __ ] and like you know i'm really
disorganized so yesterday i went through
every single scrap of paper that i have
that i write [ __ ] down on during the
show and i've transferred everything to
like one big file so i always so i have
like a big list of uh topics
that i can like rotate out and there was
like way more than i thought so and that
was the other one that i was trying to
remember because i said i know somebody
like said one about a castle and i can't
remember which one it was but i did put
um the beast of jersey in there because
i remembered somebody said something
about that but yeah i got like some i
don't remember what i put in the
i think i put in the poll this week
which one which should have gone up this
morning right it's friday yeah so the
poll went up this morning so if you're a
patron you can go on their vote but i
think i put in there i think i put
bonnie and clyde in there i think i put
the shark at shark attacks in there it
was some of the ones that like people
recommended like on the show wednesday
night so i put those in there and like i
said i put everything
everything that i could remember you
guys had suggested i put in like a big
huge long list so i put it all in one
place so it's not just on [ __ ] scraps
of paper all over my desk like usual
like i said i'm so disorganized i try to
keep [ __ ] organized but it's hard
because i have like so many things going
on at the same time you know
i'd like to do a show on the brain
some of the weird [ __ ] about the brain
like well you're gonna have to narrow it
down more than that because
that'd be like really hard to like
they had they've had these guys uh oh
well wang mentioned it today he put up a
little video like eight minutes long
they had a guy
who uh went to the doctor because his
foot stopped working and he was like in
his 50s or 40s and they did a cat scan
on his or they did an mri of his brain
and he and three quarters of his brain
were basically gone
it was just he just had a thin strip
of brain tissue that went around the
inside of his skull and had a little bit
going down the middle
and he just it was only 25 percent of
what it should what should have been
there and the only thing and the only
thing that he noticed was that his focus
kind of [ __ ] up yeah he's not sure how
to feel about that he had
he had a slightly
below average iq but lived a normal life
uh what had happened when he was a
little kid
he had that hydroencephaly yeah but they
treated it
real young when he was a baby yeah
and they thought he was normal
uh but i guess it was in some ways kind
of had had caused his brain to grow in a
certain way he had two giant empty
sockets in either hemisphere of his
brain like the size of an orange
on either side and it was just filled
with fluid
he just had a brain around the outside
of his brain case and some going down
the middle in a brain stem piece of part
of the brain stem but he had like a
relatively normal life yep i mean i
guess that's kind of inspirational
and the only explanation was is that if
the damage happens real early on and it
happens slowly the brain is rewiring
yeah it'll it'll adjust as it's as as
the shape of the brain is changing
so it reorganized itself in order to get
the job done but as far as anybody knew
he didn't have any complaints he just
started going paralyzed slightly in one
of his feet
and can you imagine having to be the
doctor that told that guy that by the
way half your brain has gone where three
quarters
three quarters three quarters just
just a thin shell it was mostly just an
empty
shell
and um
it was hollowed like an easter bunny
yeah and it kind of
got me thinking about uh stewart
ameroff's quantum soul theory stuart
hameroff said some stuff
because he's a
anesthesiologist he knows a bunch about
the brain and they're they're thinking
that there's quantum particles and
superposition going on so it's almost
like a quantum computer
happening at high temperatures which is
you know the brain is warm and wet you
know what i mean super condu super
conductivity that you need for
quantum
computing has to be done at like [ __ ]
near some near zero degrees which is
[ __ ] super cold that's almost zero
fahrenheit
you know like near zero almost you know
i think it's like [ __ ] 200 200
degrees below zero or something you know
two three hundred degrees below zero
but there's meta materials in there they
think that [ __ ]
inside your neurons that might be able
to get it done
uh photons going down there anyway
one of the things that hammer off
noticed
he noticed a bunch of [ __ ] about the
brain
these little hunting spiders those
little bitty ones they're kind of like
uh
you know
not even the size of a little pencil
eraser you know about that size right
these things can see a fly on a [ __ ]
leaf far away 78 feet away and then
pre-plan a route to get up above that
fly and jump down on it
and
if you were to cut that
[ __ ] spider open
its brain is smaller than a salt crystal
there's not hardly any neurons there
that that brain is doing more than it
should be able to do
there's not a computing power there
so hamroff says there's only one
there's only one answer to it is that
they're part of that brains in another
dimension
it's
quantum particles
it's a quantum computer in other words
it has a soul
something that you might will call a
soul
part of that creature is not in this
[ __ ] normal dimension yeah man
well it's
he's positing that it's almost kind of
like accessing something else like well
something out there is a receiver well
then a generator yeah like a kind of a
an in contact like a consciousness like
that a lot of that everybody can
everybody's brain can uh can access part
of your consciousness is not well no
i think what he's saying is he's saying
part of it is a a field
of quantum particles in superposition
all entangled with one another a soul
he called it the quantum soul theory
yeah i know and that's where most of it
is this doesn't really need much very it
doesn't need
all that much brain tissue to do a lot
of stuff as long as there's time for it
to
you know adapt to what's happening
what's that super chat say
uh thank you gadgey3 sorry i've been
awol been having seizures holy [ __ ] all
right i'll fire you more uh c wash what
does that mean see wash soon love you
guys we love you too okay uh also our
friend david is here hey how are you
doing
you're probably he's probably heading
out to b13 later
uh let's see zach says i see tom saw
wang's video too yeah yeah he said that
i said that tammy said uh i've heard
stories about people getting stabbed or
shot through the brain and surviving
yeah amazingly people do you remember
that guy what was his name phineas gage
the guy that had that like whole like
[ __ ] pipe that went through his head
blew that damn spike through his head
yeah that whole spike and it went all
the way through his head and he lived he
turned into an [ __ ] but
like his personality changed that was a
head injury yeah but that was about it
thank you thank you very much john
robertson hey guys i finally managed to
catch a live stream again just wanted to
support the channel with some money
thank you very much i've been catching
up on all your shows i finally watched
horror express it was one of the best
movies i've seen horror express is so
good which one was that that's the one
with uh peter cushing and
christopher lee on the train and that's
like the monster and the thing yeah
yeah uh holy parish of doom uh you guys
ever covered any david i is it ike or
icky david david
david icky i think his name is
hickey if that was my life
i think no we did a show on him i don't
think we did a show on him but i think
we talked about him when we did like a
show about like
didn't we do a show about like the
illuminati or something like that
because i remember we talked about
himself but i don't think we did he's
the lizard people guys he's the lizard
people guy yeah deborah says love the
blue hair jen thank you yeah i just got
this i just got this wig i think that
wig looks good i will i got three i got
a blue one a black one and a red one
because that's kind of like all the
colors i was gonna get a purple one too
but i was like well okay i can't spend
that much money come on now
but eventually i'll get because the same
company has like all different colors
yeah i kind of liked the orange one too
although i don't know what it would look
like on me see i have a theory about the
uh the lizard people [ __ ] theory
i have a theory about the lizard people
theory okay
i don't know that guy too well i've only
seen him as guests on other shows that
i'll listen to and i saw him over the
years he never really interested me that
much
recently though
when i heard that guy talking
he was talking about
he didn't talk about the lizard people
in the same way that he talked about the
lizard people before
he was kind of
he was talking about him in the way that
it was in a a
like an analogy
okay uh-huh
that
yeah because he's not saying it's
he was before he was i guess everybody
was laughing at him so he's like i
didn't really mean that yeah i meant
like metaphorically here's my theory
here's my theory
it could be
that he was afraid of getting in trouble
by talking about him okay so he thought
that if he called the lizard people and
presented it in like [ __ ] a sci-fi
way
kind of like how do they live
that
he could get he could get away with
talking about him without getting killed
because there's another guy named aj
who talks about the same [ __ ] thing
but doesn't say they're lizard people he
calls them something else
and they've done everything they did
could do to get rid of that guy it
didn't work you guys on channels and
[ __ ] now
he's back on twitter but um
so they were kinda in a way talking
about the same thing
it's just that uh that david guy
was saying that they were lizard people
but i don't know if it was a euphemism
you know or if he's trying to conceal
what he's saying and camouflaging what
he's saying
by making it sound
sci-fi
and it's of course that's a good sales
angle
because some people might be able to see
know what it is you're talking about
and then other people who are fantasy
prone will go right into it and probably
sell you send you money
so you can actually get two markets at
once
which is really kind of what arbel did
and i think arbel had him on for uh a
lot of times but i had to go back and
dig i imagine he's the art
and the thing about it is that
you know
whether he was crazy or not or really
did actually believe that or not it's
like people still talked about him and
i'm sure like people bought his books
and stuff yeah
uh recently he's not crazy i think he
was kind of maybe a crafty
businessman in certain way
um
he
sometimes
talked about things that kind of sounded
like that man that had that island with
the child and the [ __ ] who one who
did not take his own life that one and
he would say things that were like that
now when i first heard that story
aj was talking about it years before it
came out i was going on that can't be
true so that's a wild story but that
can't be true he named that [ __ ]
island and everything he says the people
people that worked there told him
yeah and that [ __ ] came out that was
absolutely true absolutely
and that he was using that as a honeypot
and getting the world's greatest
scientists as [ __ ] [ __ ] to to sign in
on this [ __ ] screw these young girls
they were taken from florida here in
ukraine
he some of them girls were from ukraine
he raised from children that's like
something out of a [ __ ] horror movie
pretty pretty girls
you could just buy them from ukraine and
there was some kind of war that was
going on he got he got him out of there
and he was using it to blackmail [ __ ]
rich powerful men and and if you look at
who's rich and real powerful
on the global stage those dudes are
[ __ ] nerds man nerds
and they didn't get any attention when
they were in high school so they're
trying to relive their high school days
or something
they got i got i got witnesses right
here they will never relive my high
school days never they wish
ain't that right granters
they're paying millions of dollars to
[ __ ] do what i did in high school
[ __ ]
[ __ ] grabbing people's young
daughters and [ __ ] they [ __ ] scum
thank you again gadgey3 thank you it
says cash by the way okay so i should
have been able to figure that out but i
could oh okay just mistyped because my
head doesn't work oh yeah that's okay
i've like i said i should have been able
to figure that out i don't know why i
didn't
[Laughter]
i've been drinking that much jesus
christ
coulda been david was talking about
those lizard people
but like i said i don't know the body of
his work i don't really know that guy he
never really
interested me
as soon as as soon as i heard lizard
people and [ __ ] i was like
and i would run into his fans online
before i ever ran into him or listen to
any of his [ __ ] you know
i just heard online that david icke was
with the lizard people
i think it's ike ike yeah david ike
maybe although you would think that
you would spell it different because it
looks like icky yeah
i don't know i don't i just don't have
time for that kind of [ __ ]
i don't have time for that kind of
[ __ ] i find it all fascinating
like i said that's why i find it off i
mean it's you know like you used to
listen to art bell show and stuff like
that and it's like funny in small deuces
but after a while i'm just like okay
nope i'm just gonna like go [ __ ] do
something else
i don't have time for that kind of crap
i can say nothing
i like it
i didn't say you weren't allowed to like
it i just said i don't it just depends
on what the subject matter is you know i
can't listen to all those guests but in
those days you didn't have a choice you
just had to listen what to listen to
what was on
you know
and sometimes he'd have good guests and
sometimes he'd have bad guess just
depended and some of the some of the
[ __ ] crazy guests that are on there
were pretty damn good there was one dude
that would [ __ ]
for a while there was like uh
they were trying to track down a time
traveler
the time traveler that did i don't think
that worked out though he kept referring
back to it
well was that the guy that we did the
show about john titor
yeah
yeah however you pronounce that dude's
last name and we did a show about that
guy and i would trip the [ __ ] out with
[ __ ] what's his name richard c
hoagland i think it's what the name is
richard he's the face on mars face on
mars guys and on the sedonia and the
cities on mars we did a show about that
too didn't we yeah i i'm sure he's got
i'm sure he's got new versions of his
[ __ ] martian theories now
he's gonna say you don't see it on the
surface but it's all subterranean you
know he's how don't you bet he's looking
right here this is a door that leads
down underneath
because every time like their [ __ ] gets
busted yeah then they have to like come
up with some new grift
yeah it was a grift you know i think but
he also had a good imagination
and
i kind of think that he
talked himself into believing that i
think he did believe it
yes i was hoping yeah i think he was
hoping you know this looks a lot like a
landing strip and here the you know
but you know the the
man they were saying they were [ __ ]
irrigation on mars going back to the
1800s [ __ ] personal lowell and all
those guys you know what i mean they
thought that the place was inhabited
because the
the mind has a very good ability to pick
out patterns and to kind of see think
you see things there that that aren't
you know well in a lot of ways that's
kind of what the human brain is for
right it's a pattern-seeking machine
because that's
because over the years that's what
natural selection has favored
is finding patterns and things obviously
um
but that doesn't mean that the pattern
you're perceiving is actually
real
it's just
you know yeah before it's just kind of
it's it's a strength of the brain but
it's also a weakness of the brain
depending on the circumstances before
the internet they could go off on all
this stuff you know and talk about the
[ __ ] on mars and the [ __ ] star child
skull or whatever and
you couldn't go online and go see what
they were talking about
you just had to trust you just had to
trust their description of it
so this [ __ ] would get built up you're
like oh man i bet you that looks badass
you know and then but then you know in
the 90s when [ __ ] prodigy and the
[ __ ] internet and [ __ ] web tv came
out you go where what's he looking at
and you go to see it you go oh yeah okay
that's yeah nah probably not you know
it's not as impressive as you'd built up
in your mind
listen to them talk about it you know
but the one that did kind of impress me
was the [ __ ] star child
talking about you remember the star
child skull yeah
i was going oh it's probably [ __ ]
you know but i'm going to go check it
out i guess oh no there it is man yeah
that does look like a [ __ ] alien had
all those teeth in it you know it was it
was weird
but it's human you know just a mutation
yeah that's all it is absolutely i think
we might have done a show about that too
like not on its own but i think we did a
show with that yeah where we talked
about it it's just i don't know i guess
that's kind of why
when i was younger like i really liked
like all that stuff like in search of
and like all that kind of stuff but then
like when i got older like the more you
think about it the more this stuff is
like not as cool or mysterious
as it seemed like like yeah back then it
was but like
when you found out more about it it
wasn't as mysterious or cool so i kind
of feel like i mean one there's a lot of
real mysteries in the world that are
like weird and [ __ ] but
i don't know i think that's kind of why
i went more and it's like i'm just gonna
like watch horror movies and like read
books and stuff because then then you
know it's fake but you can like do
whatever you want this whole reality
thing where people are trying to make
they're trying to make [ __ ] seem more
mysterious or something than it really
is
um i don't really have a lot of patience
well some of it was real though
yeah
people really did see things there
really were certain ufo
sightings that happened it's just you're
not sure what it was that they saw yeah
um
that show also art bell also had stuff
you know guys that were developing
aircraft and you know so they did have
real stuff on there they'd have
scientists on there you know talking
about black holes or physics or whatever
um so you know it wasn't all [ __ ] it
was it was a mixed it was a mixture yeah
see how like that stuff yeah
i just i just don't like when they're
trying to like take stuff that's cool
enough on its own and then they're
trying to like make it seem like super
mysterious or like it's something that
it's not you know what i mean
trying to think of what else was on that
show that was pretty awesome
back in the day david's talking about
sleep stack i was going to say that too
i was like
well the star child's going no the
lizard people elizabeth lizard people
that's the first thing that that's my
go-to like that's the first thing i
think of is the sleaze tag and then the
goron maybe but like i always think of
sleeve stacks because i used to love the
[ __ ] sleeve stacks i'm late as lost
they were like they were cool
didn't we say that we re-watched like
some of the land of the lost yeah i
re-watched about [ __ ] what maybe 10
episodes because they're on youtube yeah
they're on youtube i couldn't believe
how quick it was that the sleeve stacks
appeared because i thought it was a
while like before the sleeve stack
showed up when you're a kid it seemed to
take forever but no it was like [ __ ]
three episodes
yeah it was like two or three episodes
then and each episode is only about 15
minutes because it was all commercials
you just didn't realize it back yeah
very good
about 15 minutes an episode about that
18 minutes
not much material there
no not really it moved fast
very fast
and me and jenny were [ __ ]
like tripping the [ __ ] out or like going
because holly
how old is holly in there probably about
14 something like that 13 14. yeah
somewhere around there
she just [ __ ] can't
put her [ __ ] tongue back in her
[ __ ] head
because all she's doing is like getting
ready to blow will
yeah she's supposed to be her brother
she's supposed to be her brother
this chick is just [ __ ] melting every
time she sees him
and what was funny is that
in an interview that was just right
there she said that like that was the
most embarrassing thing about that
[ __ ] show and how she couldn't
[ __ ] stop looking at him
she had the [ __ ] super hots for him
yeah it was pretty obvious obvious i
mean obviously i didn't really catch it
at the time because i was a little kid
but it's like when you see it now she
knows it's just really obvious
she's blushing and being shy and demure
and won't leave him alone or wherever
he's going she's just just constantly
in um
animal attraction mode trying to try and
he's trying to keep it in check you can
see it's like we're trying to do a show
here yeah he's what 19 or 20.
he's trying to keep her [ __ ]
uncontrolled getting creepy yeah
[ __ ] funny
i did like the sleaze tax that way so my
favorite thing about that show was the
little pylon things
with the uh they had those like stone
tables that had all those like colored
light up buttons on it i used to think
that was so [ __ ] cool when i was a
kid remember that
yeah i like that [ __ ] yeah i like that
dopey was cool too the little uh the
little dinosaur
remember they had those like big ass
strawberries that they'd always bring
him like on the on the cart or maybe
that just happened one time i don't
really know and chaka yeah
[ __ ] chaka cam guys saying he liked
our bell when he had real guests he
wasn't too much into the ufo stuff
they're um i liked i liked all the art
bell stuff some of those guests were
just [ __ ] crazy the dude who had the
hole in the back of the [ __ ] house in
his backyard that went down to hell just
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
and uh
art was [ __ ] a really good host
because he
he treated each guest with with
honorably and
at least gave them the benefit of the
doubt you know
he would something well no no hold on
now you know he would sometimes
question some [ __ ] because it would it
would go way out there you know but he
was just a good host real good host art
was a one of a kind
yeah well there's a reason why people
still listen to that yeah
oscar's asking
how to mitigate the negative effects of
alcohol
i've been drinking like a [ __ ]
cocaine
[Laughter]
yeah i'm not sure that's a real good
answer
[Laughter]
i mean i'm sure it probably helps i'm
just saying that it might be like a
worse for you it's like replacing one
problem for a while you knew that [ __ ]
back in the cowboy days
dudes are starting nodding out at the
[ __ ] bar and hey give him [ __ ]
coca-cola pepe him up give him a pepsi
and they had cocaine and that'd wake you
back up and then they'd [ __ ] go down
and go down to the [ __ ] dentist and
go get some cocaine in the jar and bring
it back and they go pour some of that
and pour some of that in your beer
they'd put a whole bunch of that they
didn't snort it they just yeah cocaine
beer
yeah
and then how did they [ __ ] live like
what did they feel like the next day or
did they just never come down off of it
so it's like they just slept it
i mean that was just some of those
[ __ ] parties and i'd be passing out
and they'd give me some [ __ ] bump a
couple lines and you'd be right back to
it
yeah like it sobers you up
it's like a counter exit yeah you can
get right you can drink
now like i said how do you feel the next
day though i mean that's i don't know i
just [ __ ] slapped it off that's what
i mean i mean and it's probably
different when you're young
when you get our age that'd probably be
like take four days to like recover from
that [ __ ] thank you again gadgey3 oh my
goodness have more i've really missed
you this youtube ah
we have also missed yeah you know that
was that was up in boston with that
[ __ ] badass crowd and um
that was uh the barbiturates and the
[ __ ]
all the there was a there was a bunch of
dancer girls they called the
barbiturates they were [ __ ] they they
were working with a band called sleep
chamber and my buddy rich
who he was an ex-army guy he was he was
goth
uh but he was 52
when all this is going on you look at
him
he didn't look 52 he looked like he
barely about 32.
um people thought we were brothers we
kind of looked alike he was
we're about the same size he was a
little more slender kind of skinny guy
and he ended up blowing his head off
in an argument
with he did a used a 38 special revolver
his five shot snub nose [ __ ] pulled
out [ __ ] blew his head off right in
front of his girlfriend fighting over
the damn volume of the television set
they were watching excalibur
and uh the girl's name was the girl's
name was [ __ ] um
soleil
and she was this hot
kinda
octoroon type
girl from l.a and they were all junkies
they were they were good people but they
got they got wrapped up in heroin
and um they would
snort heroin and snort coke and drink
fifths of [ __ ] liquor and sleep most
the time and they're just like vampires
she was only
22 23 he was about
51 i think 52.
and uh
he was start i don't know why he had you
know he he was living the life i mean
he had a good job and
he didn't have any heavy
responsibilities
um he also was i think he got va money
too
so
and he was
popular you know [ __ ] and uh had
young beautiful girlfriends and
yeah of course drugs were always
involved but that's just the way that
scene is and just
just a moment of weakness he [ __ ]
shot himself in the head dumbass well he
probably wasn't thinking that much about
it i'm sure he instantly regretted it
regret it like well i mean he would have
instantly regretted he actually could
have yeah
because his girlfriend was
like [ __ ] hot man really high and he
didn't and and that's all he ever hooked
up with was [ __ ] hotties and i'm
talking on a scale of one of tens
they're like eights and nines
and
goth girls
and uh old school the classic types you
know with the skirts and the [ __ ]
kind of mohawks and fauxhawk types you
know what i mean death rocker looking
type chicks
i just
i don't know why you know just bad day
yeah everybody has one and the thing
about it is that you can't really like
judge
from the outside like sometimes it looks
like one person oh they had this that
and the other thing but you don't know
like what's
what that person's like thought
processes are so you know what i mean
like maybe it doesn't seem that way to
them or maybe they have like some other
problems that you don't know about or
something like that to do with something
else though he would um
i could show up to his apartment and
[ __ ] knock on his door and the door
would never open and i'd i'd hear i'd
hear one of his girlfriend go come in
that kind of [ __ ] you know and i tried
to open the door and come in and the cat
greet me i'm after the head little
[ __ ] cat the cat would run up and
he'd be laying at us come on we're gonna
get him up out of here let's go let's go
to the club
and she's like
rich wake up wake up richie because he's
passed out wake up retching where is he
worthless when she's slapping at him
come on what are you doing because he's
going to sleep all night you know
because he was [ __ ] on heroin
she'd [ __ ] get him up though you know
and she'd get him up and once he got
started moving he'd be all right
and then that dude started snorting coke
and then he would go to the [ __ ] club
and drink at the club
and then we'd go back to his place
and he'd drink a half a [ __ ] fifth of
[ __ ] vodka talking all [ __ ] night
he nod out a little bit and then he
[ __ ] snap up i don't know how his
[ __ ] liver and his kidneys could
could take it that's what i'm saying
it's like somebody who is 50 something
years old he's my age
i mean like i said when you're younger
you can get away with a lot of that kind
of stuff i mean it'll catch up with you
in the end i didn't really drink that
much when i was younger like i didn't
actually really start drinking till i
was like in my late 30s so i didn't have
all that like kind of baggage about it
but the thing about it now is like you
know i'm almost 50 so it's kind of like
now if i go out and drink all night
even if i get some sleep yeah like the
next day i'm gonna be like i don't i
don't really get too bad at hangovers if
i remember to take aspirin before i go
to sleep and drink a whole bunch of
water like if i drink a whole bunch of
water take a couple aspirin and go to
sleep and then sometimes i'll wake up
around three or four in the morning
because i have to pee and then i'll take
a couple more aspirin and then usually
um i feel okay the next day like not i
don't usually have a headache i don't
usually feel too much nausea sometimes a
little bit but not too much i'll get
real tired like i'll be really tired
like the following afternoon like you
know nodding off and stuff but i don't
usually get hangovers too bad now if i
forget to take aspirin before i go to
sleep and drink water then yeah
and sometimes it helps too to kind of
eat some sort of greasy ass food that's
why we usually like on the way home
we'll usually stop and get like a like a
big mac or some [ __ ] like that yeah um
you know because that actually does help
yeah
yeah it's just a trip time
poor rich
well as oscar said all it takes is one
bad day yeah that's what i mean yeah and
the thing about it is that
um you know and it happens to a lot of
people you get
[ __ ] up and drunk or you get [ __ ] up
and high or you you know get really
really mad or something like that and
all it takes is a second
where you're not really thinking
straight because you're mad or high or
drunk or all three and you make a really
stupid decision that like affects
everything for the rest of your life
whether you kill yourself or you kill
somebody else or some [ __ ] like that so
you know he was fighting he was fighting
with her over the volume of the [ __ ]
television over [ __ ]
she wanted to turn it down and he was
trying to turn it up and then he got
into a big fight you know blah blah blah
and you don't know honor you you have no
honor and blah blah you know this you
have no honor because you want the tv to
well it was more than that i don't know
everything that's what i'm saying like i
joke but yeah she didn't tell me
everything arguments are always about
more than yeah
more than the actual thing
he ducks off into the walk-in closet for
like a second
and then [ __ ] comes back out and his
army dressed green's [ __ ] top
all right with the [ __ ] 38 special
revolver in his hand because i'm [ __ ]
sick you i'm out of here boom and blew
his head off right in front of her
she goes no she called the cops and the
cops came they picked up his body took
the gun
she stayed in there for a while she had
her friends came and got her
had to move all her [ __ ] out of his yeah
but she had to stay there [ __ ] blood
pool where the body was
she tried to revive him but the [ __ ]
hole went right through his head
shot right through the [ __ ] top is
down
38 special at point blank and like i
said it's he probably was not thinking
about it yeah he probably wasn't
thinking i'm sick i'm out of here boom
blew his head up
and like you said i know she didn't kill
him
yeah she didn't kill him no way
she wasn't the type
camp guy says they have cocaine eye
drops that ophthalmologists use for
temporary pain relief when you have a
corneal abrasion yeah my kid scratched
my cornea when he was like 18 months old
the doctor said it was one of the worst
you'd seen yeah the eye drops only work
for about 15 minutes so you're in agony
the rest of the time
i didn't actually know that they have
like cocaine ones
yeah he was in his dress green tops
he was a spec four he was only in one
enlistment
oscar also says taking aspirin after a
night of drinking does extra damage to
your liver well
that horse has left the barn gonna say
and like i said i'm not really that
worried about it just because
i didn't really drink
hardly at all
when i was a teenager in my 20s
like i said so i didn't really start
drinking so it's not like i've been
drinking like for 30 years or something
like that you know what i mean
i don't know that's my story and i'm
sticking to it
and we don't drink every night
you know
well chevy's asking us a question
i listened to your ed lorraine warren
podcast a year or two ago i was
wondering if you guys believe in them
and their work or if you didn't because
of the
of the book sales or movies
um yeah we've done a didn't we do like a
a redux on ed and lorraine i think i
think we i think we've done two shows
because i think we did one show like a
long time ago yes that's our one of our
most popular shows i think and the one
that gets the most negative comments i
should know well though i haven't got
any for a long time and then we did
another one where you talked about like
some of their lesser known cases
um honestly i kind of feel like they
were full of [ __ ] but
i don't think that lorraine i think
lorraine actually did believe in this
stuff
um
maybe they both did but
i kind of feel like they were mostly in
it like for the for the grift yeah
pretty much they were grifted i mean
they would they would turn up at
places where they didn't get invited
like enfield and stuff like that yeah
they were actually involved in some real
cases enfield being one of them they
weren't invited to that case they just
was trying to get him out tried to get
him out of it get him out of there he
was not a parapsychologist he called
himself a demonologist
which is you can just re you can just
pull [ __ ] out of your ass if you're a
demonologist okay
which if you listen to what they're
saying about the cases that they are
that they're on they are just making up
explanations you're pulling it out of
their ass you know
um using religion as an explanation for
everything when there could be other
things what about parapsychology what
about you know rspk recurrent
spontaneous psychokinesis you know what
what if it's mentalism you know what if
it's uh something in the air they don't
do a proper investigation they just come
in and go yep demons demons yeah and
we'll get the holy water i think this is
kind of like what do they call that a
maslow's hammer situation where it's
like if you know all the only tool you
have is a hammer then every problem
looks like a nail so i kind of feel like
because they were demonologists
every single case they showed up at well
damon
and we know how to solve that problem
they like didn't even try to look for
other solutions i kind of feel like and
um
the more sensational the case the more
ed and lorraine more ed would kick up
dust about it and try to get
the the media involved all right and
then the result secondary sales and
stuff that they were involved in and
trying to go on talk shows
a lot
um
it's just uh
too many demons around those two what's
this what is the static statistical
probabilities
you know very improbable uh no they're
no they i think they were on some real
cases
yeah i mean they did get called into
some [ __ ] where some genuinely weird
[ __ ] was going on yeah but their
explanation was demons no matter what it
was yeah
and because that was their angle yeah
and some people
um
worked with them or on the same cases
and they said that
ed would do things like
i'm just trying to remember just off the
top of my head
they would see something that was a
piece of evidence against anything
paranormal going on and he said he'd
hide that i want to worry about that we
gotta fight the demons you know what i
mean he was one of those he wasn't
trying to get down the truth of it
no yes i mean
you know
it's just kind of like look i don't
begrudge people like trying to make a
living okay um
by selling books or doing lectures or
whatever because they did that yeah
she's got books that's what i'm saying
but they're not she's not an
investigator though
yeah and i'm not going to like people's
house who are actually like having
problems
and saying that i know what their
problem is and i'm gonna solve
everything for you and like give me some
money or whatever i don't know if they
charge like the actual people or if they
just use their stuff as like fodder for
later i'm not really sure
best modern investigator i've been able
to find
with steve mara and i put that i put him
in contact with her and they've done a
couple books together
what i like about steve is that steve is
fair
if he investigates something he'll give
he'll give you both sides of what it
could or may have been or may not have
been and he talks about what is good
evidence and not good evidence he leaves
it up to you to pick through
most probably what is happening here you
know
um
now some of those cases over time i
think got a little crazy
like a house of fire and whispers that
that started off as a good case
but um i think the the the center of
that case i think he got so obsessed
with that [ __ ] is that he i think he
started to fabricate stuff
not steve mara though no not steve the
guy the guy who was having that problem
what was his name
bender keith lynn i think keith linder
over time became so obsessed with that
that he he didn't want the phenomena to
stop and he wanted to get stronger and
stronger and if he had a fake [ __ ] to
get attention i think he would
that's but steve when he was there did
see some stuff that he wasn't he that
wasn't she didn't see some bad [ __ ] he
saw some weird [ __ ] yeah because me and
steve wrote a book about because keith
wrote his own book about what happened
to them in the case the book that i
wrote was steve
that was just about
the three weeks however long it was two
or three weeks that steve was there yeah
and what steve saw so i wrote it from
steve's point of view because he went to
seattle from england and like
investigated it and was there for a
couple of weeks and then came back later
on like for another nine days or
something and he did see some weird [ __ ]
um
so i just read about it from that i'm
not like taking a stand on whether the
[ __ ] really happened or not i'm just
saying like that's what steve
told me that he saw and that was like
all the [ __ ] that he like all the
evidence that he had i don't know about
like
i don't know about the rest of the thing
and i haven't read keith's book either
because keith wrote his own book like i
said yeah
yeah who knows what that's about
yeah i probably should read that i feel
like just um just for my own edification
steve had that [ __ ] place wired up
with cameras and uh microphones and had
it under control of like a a central
like sound board
yeah he lived there for two weeks him
and the other guy like they moved in
yeah for two weeks some of the weird
stuff that that he got and jenny wrote
about it
he has all the evidence still too
it's at certain at one certain time
something fell off a wall dude i don't
remember exactly what it was it was uh
it was like a light fixture a light
fixture yeah
and he knows the exact time that it fell
and when it hit
it made a certain sound signature when
he went up there to try to reproduce
that sound signature again it was the
same signature but the decimal age was
wrong yeah
which is that's something i've noticed
in poltergeist cases that have happened
around me
is that when something hits the ground
it doesn't quite sound right
like it's heavier than it like it's
heavier than it should be yeah like it
made more noise than it should have
it's just a weird phenomenon which is
why i thought that one particular thing
in that case was interesting
because he actually measured because
they had like i said they had the whole
house he lived there he moved in with
keith and him and his uh the other guy
that was with him the other pair of
psychologists both of them moved in
there and they lived there for like two
weeks i think it was yeah and they had
the whole [ __ ] wired up they had like
audio and video and they had everything
like all over and uh motion sensors and
all that kind of crap
so when that light fell down
in the
hallway
like they went up there and they tried
everything to
make it sound like it would normally
sound if it just fell off of if it just
fell off the wall like by itself but it
the sound that it made as recorded by
the audio thing and i've seen the graphs
and everything was like way way way
louder than anything they could
reproduce yeah
and there were several things like that
that happened and some light weird light
phenomenon i think uh i don't remember
everything that it was but steve steve
did say that
he thought there was something happening
in that in that house
but
he
yeah
later on
the whole lender thing he thinks that
that went sideways afterwards he he
thinks that linder got
obsessed with that case and because he
didn't get national attention
he was trying to bring national
attention to it and maybe start to fake
stuff
which spoils the whole case if you ask
me as soon as somebody starts faking
[ __ ] then you go well how long have you
been faking [ __ ] yeah because then
people can like discredit it
but the thing is is that the [ __ ] that
steve saw he got got a recording he has
recordings of it happening
so that happens sometimes on a case
where there
it's a mixture of real phenomena and
then people coming in to think of stuff
to try to get more attention that's
happened before
well yeah and the thing about it was
that i mean when the [ __ ] started i'm
not saying i don't believe keith because
i do but like the [ __ ] that happened he
got really interested in it but like you
said as the time went on he got obsessed
with it i mean he
even when even before he called steve
and before all this stuff uh you know
before he brought in like other like
parapsychologists and stuff he was like
he installed cameras all over the house
and he was keeping track of all this
because he got like really interested in
what was going on even where is that
raccoon
yeah pretty much
pretty much
um
shelby says i hope i still love horror
when i'm old lol yeah i mean you
probably will i don't know how old you
are right now
but i mean i've loved horror since i can
remember so since i was a tiny child
um and i'm almost 50 and i still love
that [ __ ] i forgot to mention um
something happened um
a couple weeks back i forgot to mention
it on the show yeah i kept i told you
the other day i was like you didn't even
say like someone you had some more like
how long ago was that last week or the
week before something i don't know i
kicked bumblebees
i was looking for something i was in the
man cave i was looking for something i
think it might have been a hammer or
there was some kind of tool or something
i was looking for
and i got this bookshelf with a bunch of
stuff on it
one of the things on it
they had at that time was a stainless
steel ring had a skull
that my other girlfriend gave me from
the i call her my other girlfriend
one of the waitresses up at the damn
another which is one of the bartenders
your backup girl my backup girlfriend
that's my biker girlfriend
she's a biker girl all right and she's
you guys saw her she's a [ __ ] trip
all right
she gave me a stainless steel ring i
took it i said she said look at that she
gave me all these rings and i said i'm
gonna take that she's are you gonna take
it yeah i'm gonna take it and i took it
and she said you sold it i just took it
i put it on and then i got we're married
now she goes also you my husband and i
said yeah he goes with it what's your
wife going to take you know she's this
girl right it was just i played i
started to play that whole game she's
like you're my husband i was just like
uh where's my alimony yeah
that's what i would do yeah she
anyway tom has a harem he's like a hero
so then like i have that ring
and um i had it on top of that bookshelf
there's a it was next to a bunch of the
ar15 uppers that i had had some stacked
on top three ar-15 uppers and had a
little ring sitting there and i was
looking for a tool
and as my eyes were scanning across it
my eye just touched that ring and when i
looked away i saw it go
and hit the ground poof
and then like and then i was like one
two three about three seconds later i
went wait a minute how'd that happen
and i looked down the ring was on the
ground
and when it moved
it looked like like it was weightless
like a leaf blowing away in the wind
that's what it looked like
it was a stainless steel ring
so
when i looked at it i just looked at
when i looked away
and you know it's the same thing from
mammoth mountain it's just that it
doesn't it's not as
it's not as common as it used to be it's
and it's always when i'm kind of
frustrated or lots of fear fear or
frustration with me that
it'll do it
yeah i mean when we haven't seen it
we've had guests over here seen it when
we had the whole thing
um
that where you had like the thing with
the remote control like flying off the
table and stuff like that when dimitri
and jen were here
yeah the reason that happened was
because we were trying to
buy
mad max fury road like on paper we were
trying to rent it and it wasn't working
like we were having technical
difficulties and tom was getting pissed
off because he really wanted to be true
and chad to see this movie and
so that i kind of feel like that's
probably what so again that was like
frustration whenever you get like really
really frustrated or really really angry
and when it happens
it happens right in front of me and i
kind of don't see it or don't care when
it happens
i have to think and it's afterwards i'm
like wait a minute
because it tends to look like wind
like when that shot glass fell through
that same thing that was
i don't know i think i told that already
yeah this is in the old house
i was playing a video game and i was
getting all into it i must have get
frustrated or something and the same
bookcase that i was talking about was
next to the video game or the television
at that time
in the old house
and
i saw the curtains move like a wind but
that never happens it was like a wind
blowing through the house i was looking
at the screen but i saw those curtains
move
and i saw a streak go down straight down
like a streak of white just straight
down and at the bot and it got to the
bottom
shelf and it went
then i looked and it was a plastic shot
glass
that i was using to measure e-liquid to
make my own leak liquid
and it was sitting on its base vibrating
and it had fallen through all of the
five
shelves in that bookcase
it didn't come out and go in it just
went straight down but i wasn't looking
directly at it it just looked like a
white streak
and i guess it moved the curtains about
and what was funny is that i went i saw
that happen and i just went and it
didn't even scare me i was just like
happy and then i paused it it went over
there and went what
and i was just trying when i was a kid
that would have scared me so bad i would
have jumped out of my [ __ ] skin well
now old hat now yeah
and then it
then the fear would have started to
[ __ ] snowball and the the effect
would have increased because i would
have seen it as an outside force [ __ ]
with me
but it's something in another one of the
facets of your personality it's probably
that one that
you know
the human mind is almost kind of like a
multiplicity of [ __ ]
different facets or different
personalities talking to you and about
you and to each other and then they kind
of come to a consensus and make a
decision and then it comes out of what
you consider to be your consciousness
you know
your brain so your mind is just this
constant conversation
um so it's stuff that's happening in
your kids and super egos you know that's
freudian [ __ ] i think he's full of [ __ ]
but it's just outside the conscious
realm
and um
i got one of them in there it sounds
like that venom thing you know what i
mean like you'd be nothing without me
you know that kind of [ __ ] this is that
kind of [ __ ] all right i think it's
that's the one that does it
you know it's also kind of like uh
jenny's heard it
it says i'm gonna kill you a lot it says
that a lot
there's always you're always saying that
yeah it's saying it to me
uh then like uh
then um
he's always saying that like he's all
like in the shower while he's cooking
yeah it's it's just trying to kill me
while he's sleeping yeah
and then um i'm used to it it's kind of
like it's because i know he's not
talking it's not directed at me no it's
talking to me yeah so don't worry about
it yeah
it's one of them in there is [ __ ]
angry at me and then uh
but it's also
um
in that mummy movie
that
mr hyde
what's that russell crowe russell
russell crow is mr hyde that's it
as soon as he started talking
i'm like that's it that's that thing
that's that thing that's that's that's
talking to me that or like i said jack
torrance walking down the hallway
right
right right
i was like hey that's you yeah
yeah it's that and venom and jack
torrance yeah that's why he like relates
to those movies so hard yeah it's like
hey i just i just i feel seen
that's my dark side yeah that's the dark
side all right got some comments i gotta
catch up on okay david says gotta go v13
tonight
yeah so have fun uh yeah we're probably
gonna set up dude i'm broke and like
next week well we'll either go next week
we gotta go to the new we gotta check
out the new momento mori but that's not
at mannequins that's at barbarella so
yeah that's like a long drive but we
gotta go i gotta check out the new
barbarella because we haven't been yet
danny rowling says just saw cannonball
run that movie doesn't hold up at all
just saying uh yeah we want to rewatch
that uh i still liked smoking the bandit
interestingly when we were seeing fire
starter at the theater uh fathom events
is showing smokey and the bandit on the
big screen for the movie's 40th
anniversary yeah so
you have to pay for that because it's
fathom smoking abandoned two is pretty
good too
yeah yeah yeah but i haven't so we've
been meaning to re-watch like cannonball
run but we haven't we haven't done it
yet uh thank you thank you again gadgey3
gave us some more money bedtime for me
love you guys love the blue hair too oh
thank you so much thank you for dropping
by this evening we miss you we hope you
will come back on one of our live
streams we're on all the time you know
uh tammy says i'm 53 and i love horror
and i've always been into it yeah i kind
of feel like if it's just something that
you're into like
i i feel like it's something that
doesn't go away i mean i never
it's funny because i kind of feel like
my like you know my parents weren't like
weird about it or anything but i think
they thought that
i was gonna outgrow it because like when
i was a little kid i was like ooh ghost
stories which is blah blah and i was
like all into that kind of stuff and i
kind of feel like well she'll outgrow it
it's fine you know what i mean she's a
little weird now but but i never did you
know what i mean
because i kind of feel like if you're
into that [ __ ] you're into that [ __ ] i
mean that's just i don't i don't know
how to be any different to be honest
with you i just love that [ __ ]
um
oh man oscar goes kitty kitty kitty yeah
yeah he remembers that story
yeah we were gonna yeah we were gonna do
a show about that man i wish uh i have
that somewhere somebody asked if um what
do you guys think of the carla moran
case that inspired the film entity i
think we should do a show about that
because we did actually talk about her
case a long time it might have been
episode one
uh because didn't we talk about the case
behind the entity i kind of feel like it
was episode one or something like that
and because we talked about the shining
as well
but i would really like to talk about
that case
i don't know i kind of feel like
um
i'm not sure where i fall on it because
some of the claims that she makes are
pretty out there
now the movie the entity i do like that
movie
but the end of it is
batshit crazy yeah
and it doesn't really have anything to
do with like what really happened
but it's a good movie otherwise but the
end is batshit crazy
but yeah we should do another show about
that so i wrote it down carla moran
because that's another one that i wanted
to do i wanted to do like because some
people have asked us to do more like
more paranormal shows i want to do like
more episodes of haunting i want to do a
carla moran show i want to do a show
about the ammons haunting
actually you remember zach baggins he
bought the house
they called that the demon house too and
that was like a [ __ ] crazy
poltergeist case too like i uh it was
supposed to be demon possession but you
know i wrote about that in my booktubes
that was like a crazy case too but i
want to do one about that shelby says i
met old like ed and lorraine
50 isn't old that was the one thing i
felt interesting about them is how they
stood their ground to the end i couldn't
imagine my granny being in that position
yeah yeah i mean they weren't old when
they were doing all that though [ __ ]
a lot of them a lot of that time they
were in their 40s 50s 30s
ed
ed was up in there living in the house
with his wife and then like his 16 year
old girlfriend was living in with him
too so
it's just
no no those people were
they were grifted
they were grifted but to an extent i do
think i mean i think at least lorraine
i think they really did believe in
demons and [ __ ] yeah i think i don't
know if ed did but i think legitimately
i think they believed in demons i think
they legitimately believed yeah i think
they were very very religious yeah i
think they believed in david's uh but i
also believed that ed knew that he was
uh uh uh [ __ ] um
hoaxing all right
he was exaggerating he would yeah he
would sensationalize everything
and i i think that
based on some of the cases that he went
on he went on on he probably did see
uh some paranormal stuff although his
best case would have been enfield
and enfield scared cops that went to it
and um
he didn't come back with any really good
stories though i think he well it was
the [ __ ] just showed up real quick
and then left yeah from what i heard
yeah i mean because like i said the
enfield case that took place in england
yeah
and i think that the from from what i
know i think the warrens just showed up
there because it was a high profile case
and they're like we need to get in on
this just like they turned up at
amityville even though nobody called
them yeah um but enfield they flew over
there they turned up and somebody like
guy lion playfair and morris gross and
them they were already on the case
and they're like these americans turned
up one day at the door and we didn't
really know who they were
and they're like they want to
investigate and stuff and they're like
nah bro we got it and so i don't even
think
i mean they were there for like a day
and then they left
and i don't really know how much they
did at the site because there was
already like i said a pair of
psychologists there the you know the
media guy was already there like people
were already there like
handling it
so
i kind of feel like they so the thing
about it is that
when they made the movie it wasn't the
first conjuring because that was about
what's
the first conjuring who was that based
on [ __ ] now i can't remember
i'll remember in a minute but the second
conjuring
wait was the second conjuring movie
based on enfield i thought it was one of
them was
and they're making you know what you're
talking about oscar now the enfield no
she was not autistic
i just feel like they're making it seem
like the warrens were like the only
people investigating enfield or
were and they absolutely were not yeah
there was already a team investigating
that when they got there and according
to all of them they're like look the
warrants just showed up one day we
didn't really know who they were they
just turned up their uninvited yeah the
um the enfield case had lots of [ __ ]
rspk uh recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis the police saw it
newspaper people saw it
uh people could just go into the house
and [ __ ] watch it once that kid would
relax around you
um
things would be thrown or and it's just
from impossible
we have the book i have the book here
guy lying playfail wrote the damn book
on the whole thing and as soon as i read
it it was like yeah that's exactly what
we saw at mammoth exactly
the same order of how it would went from
small to big
um how the activity would kind of ebb
and flow over the day
um that's it when i was a kid i could do
that and i'm not autistic
yeah i mean
they did fake some things but they
caught them yeah and the thing is is
that
faking things a lot of times has to do
with priming the pump
the kid is trying to put on this psychic
performance for the people
and if the people don't believe it it's
harder to do it
so faking something and getting their
confidence up can help the [ __ ]
to help the [ __ ] the force flow if
that's what i put it that would be a
good way to put it
the main thing is faith
believing that it will happen
if you believe that it and then as soon
as you see it happening you know it's
happening then it becomes it becomes
easier
well and another thing is is that if you
attribute it to an outsider that's what
i was just gonna say that makes it even
easier
so if you believe it's a ghost or a
demon it starts to actually
mimic something like a ghost or a demon
even though it's you yeah even though
it's well that's tom's theory yeah well
which sounds legit i mean most people
believe that that's what it is
i know that's what it is
it makes a lot of sense because like i
said
we had like minor [ __ ] happen
at the old house and according to you i
haven't seen anything like
really weird at this house but you had
that
you had that happen so oh but in the
kitchen
well no i mean you had that ring fly
around oh yeah
in the new house yeah that wasn't really
weird though the uh the the the
i would think that the the remote one
was weirder it yeah it was weird or when
it took and because there was like a
bunch of people that saw that yeah we
all saw that right and when the uh
nobody else saw it but the when it
[ __ ] threw down the [ __ ] statues
of the horses and tore the [ __ ]
railing off yeah i just saw the
aftermath of man it happened
at work it happened and once i turned my
back and it went boom and [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] i thought
lightning struck and i see the [ __ ]
horses hitting and the [ __ ]
pulled down the damn
railing off the top of the
kitchen cabinets
that one was pretty good
um
but that was nothing compared to when i
was
13.
when i was 13 was even better
dj maniac says going to see octavio in a
bit all right all right tell him hi
foreign ass for me
see that was from tom
tom wanted to molest you
sorry sergeant deadhead said uh he liked
our background thank you very much also
uh does somebody refill off screen no
tom usually goes and refills yeah yeah
he just goes in because we have like a
little
a little it's not really a bar but we
have like a little mini fridge and a
little ice machine
like the next room over and he goes in
there and makes like uh drinks now
right and what down right and what down
what writing it down too no i'm writing
it down uh that danny rowling said the
jackie hernandez san pedro haunting that
was another one that i wanted to do a
show about that we never did so thank
you for reminding me of that so that's
why i'm writing them down i'm writing
down like people's recommendations so i
can put it on my list yeah um let's see
such a deal
yeah the first one was about bathsheba
sherman that's right i had forgotten
like i actually like the first conjuring
but i don't love it as much as some
people do somebody asked a long time and
i can't remember who it was because it
was a while back but um somebody asked
what
we thought the best
haunted house
or like ghost movies were
best haunted house movies well best for
best for what i mean there's a lot of
different kinds of best for like
accuracy or of like no just like ones no
just the movies that are that you like
the best i mean that seemed pretty
obvious the best haunted house movies
what you think of the best haunted house
movies um i'm gonna say
the haunting from 1963 based on haunting
of hillhouse by shirley jackson uh
easily one of my favorite horror movies
of all time and my favorite haunted
house movie of all time
um
haunting uh no it's uh haunting of hell
house legend of hell house yeah based on
the richard matheson yeah which one
legend of house
was calling roddy mcdowell right yeah
yeah yeah that's a good one and uh
pamela franklin yeah i would i i would
say burnt off burn offerings that's the
next one that i was gonna say burnt
offerings is [ __ ] great uh the book
is good too uh it's a little bit
different than the movie just in the
sense that there's more
kind of character development at the
beginning but other than that it's like
pretty close to the book but yeah burnt
offerings is great with oliver reed and
karen black
um other haunted house ones haunted
house ones haunted houses i mean haunted
house movies that's probably my favorite
sub-genre of horror i really really like
haunted heads i never get tired of them
i really really like them but um yeah
let's see what do do do do is the
changeling changelings it's kind of a
haunted house that's a haunted house
movie yeah that i can't think i know
there's new ones that i liked
but i can't like think of what they
i can't think of any like offhand at the
minute like i probably will think of
some like later but there's cess what's
up sass
i think she was here earlier
my favorite has always been the original
amityville and i like the second one as
well the brother and sister [ __ ] is
disturbing i you know what um i like the
original amityville 2 i don't like it as
much as i did when i was a kid because
it scared the crap out of me like the
first time i saw it but it's not as
scary now
but i remember the second one also being
good so i've been wanting to rewatch
that but i haven't do you know that
there are like [ __ ]
19 or 20 amityville movies nowadays i
don't even think they were made by
they're not like sequels or nothing like
that because amityville
i mean the story it's not
copyrighted
so anybody could make an amityville
movie as long as you don't use anybody's
real name or nothing like that as far as
i know
legally you're on solid ground right
like you can't i don't think you can use
the actual house well the actual house
doesn't even look like that anymore
anyway because they changed it so it
wouldn't look like that anymore because
they were sick of everybody like camping
on their lawn and [ __ ]
dj maniac says the changeling is more of
a haunted attic movie
well i don't know the ball comes down
the stairs that's that qualifies as like
the whole house being haunted
you know
and let's see what else oscar says if
you have a voice your head saying i'm
gonna kill you you need to get it
checked out well yeah why
[ __ ] uh killing people's normal for
me that was my that was my job you know
so that well nowadays nowadays probably
not not a good idea yeah but you know
that was that's just like somebody i'm
gonna make you a taco you know or i'm
gonna [ __ ] wash your floor that was
just a job to me
but uh no i [ __ ] there's
people have
more than one personality there's kind
of like a facet going on in your
subconscious
and some of them are stronger than the
other ones you're kind of like a little
bit of a multiple and they're all kind
of talking and the end result is what
you would consider to be your conscious
those decisions that you're making
were made in your subconscious long
before you're even aware of them
just that as
whatever your personality is like
there's other facets of you in there
that are the opposites of all that in
there all right and the stronger you are
the stronger they are
the more experienced and the more
uh [ __ ] the bigger your life is out
here the bigger their life is in there
and uh
you know there's one in there it's like
[ __ ] mr hyde
and uh i gotta keep that [ __ ] in check
[Laughter]
and he doesn't like me
you know
yeah
well i mean i have a person inside that
doesn't like me too yeah
it's probably not as mean as your well i
don't know it might be it might be but
you know i try not to like uh listen to
her
mr 88 says the innocence is great it is
yeah i did a review on that i think i
did that like during my halloween week
that i did because i love that movie i
bought it like just specifically so i
could do
uh a show about it so so creepy
shelby says have you guys ever done a
show on the exorcist i know you did the
second one i saw that movie at eight
years old and i've never been the same
you know what did have we ever done the
original exorcist we did
exorcist two the heretic we did exorcist
three
we did
exorcist dominion or whatever the
prequel was that they made a few years
back have we ever done the original
no i don't think so oh i don't think we
have
i maybe okay the thing about it was that
when we first started doing movie
reviews on the channel which was
a long time ago probably four or five
years ago
we
initially or at least i initially
i wanted to do horror that
hadn't been covered as much like yeah we
talked about the shining and stuff like
that but i wanted to do movies that were
like
that i really liked but i didn't really
see a lot of other channels talking
about
so i kind of feel like for a long time
we very deliberately
didn't do like a lot of the classics
like the exorcist or halloween or
anything like that because i said well i
feel like everybody has said everything
that can be said on those movies
and i don't really know if i could bring
anything new to the table i was kind of
more interested in doing stuff that
that maybe like people weren't like that
weren't maybe as well known i guess so
we were kind of talking about [ __ ] like
logan's run or
you know legend of hell house or
something like that where
you know they were kind of well known in
the horror community but i kind of feel
like why you know wider kind of people
didn't know because even even people
that aren't super into horror
have heard of the exorcist and have
heard of halloween and i've heard of
those movies but i kind of feel like the
next tier the couple next tiers down
which are also really really awesome
um you know we did one like life force
and [ __ ] like that and
you know those are ones that don't
really get as much love so i've always
tried it and plus like i said i'm not
arrogant enough to think that i have
some like
you know amazing new insights on
movies like the exorcist or
psycho or something like that that
everybody
has and their mom has like talked about
um you know and i'm not saying i don't
love those movies because i do but i
just don't know if i could like
bring any kind of like new perspective
to the table that hasn't i would rather
like
i don't know talk about movies that
don't get talked about all that much i
guess but we've done some popular ones
as well i kind of feel like lately we've
been trying to do ones that we missed
out on but i still can't believe that we
haven't done the original exorcist
did we now that i'm thinking about it i
think we've done every single other
exorcism
but that one
thank you
yeah because i remember yeah because we
did exercise to the heretic not too long
ago because that movie was terrible this
is the last of that so i'm probably have
to go on the uh
vodka after this okay well you're back
up you drinking my vodka how much well i
got a lot of vodka i got a lot of vodka
though
because i thought i bought a bottle and
i thought you bought a bottle when you
were out the other day
danny rowling says uh jenny's wig makes
me want one of those blue old-school
juice barrel jug drinks with the tinfoil
lid oh my god i remember those we used
to get those because my mom and dad used
to like run a daycare and they would get
because they were cheap right so you
could get them like in bulk and they
would get them for like the little kids
like all the different [ __ ] flavors
with the little lit little [ __ ] foil
lids on them
deadhead starting dead is going to some
excel at it yeah boy i don't know what
you're talking about there's no uh
there's no um
context there
then shelby said something about you
should i listen to the audiobook i want
to people pass what audio book on what
oscar says you guys should do an
exorcist retrospective review an x from
this year of course i swear god i'm
gonna do it actually later if i remember
i'll write it down if i remember i'm
gonna look how much it costs to like
rent it and i'm gonna rent it because
everybody has told me to like watch it
i'm trying to keep up with new [ __ ] look
look last night
on shutter i haven't finished watching
it yet because it was getting late
shutter just added
the fangoria
2022 chainsaw awards
so they're giving like awards for all
the best horror movies from like last
year
so some of them i'd heard of and some of
them i hadn't so i was just kind of like
oh i gotta watch this because it'll give
me like some ideas look at like i need
any more movies to like add to my
[ __ ] list but you know because
there's still like a few from like the
last five six years that i haven't seen
yet that i need to catch up on
but
so i so i wrote down like a few more
from there
i don't know i'm really trying to like
i mean
i did
for tomorrow like the review that i did
for tomorrow is for the sadness and
that's like one of the newest movies
that i've ever done right that came out
this year
this year
you should probably i wouldn't mind
watching again you should probably watch
it watch what the sadness yeah you said
it's on shutter yeah everybody's telling
me to watch it they got [ __ ] two or
three people in there saying oh he's got
to see this he's got to see that i can't
i still can't believe that you've never
seen dead alive because that seems like
that would be right up your [ __ ]
alley what's that about it's like it's
kind of like a zombie movie but it's
like it's pretty much the goriest film
ever made it's it's funny because it's
peter jackson who later on would go on
to do lord of the rings and all that
but when he first started out i mean
he's like bad taste and he did like
super super like over the top like gory
movies yeah dead alive is one of the
goriest things if not the goriest thing
i've ever seen and it's hilarious yeah
it's hilarious like the gore gags in it
are so funny it's kind of like
it's like an evil dead type situation
where it's just kind of like it's really
gory but it's like so over the top that
it's funny
the sadness is kind of different like
it's really really gory
but
it's not supposed to be funny like it's
not so over the top that it's funny you
know what i mean it's just like really
really gory so i don't know i really
liked it but
i'm getting i'm on like a couple horror
groups on facebook
and i feel like the sadness is the one
that's like the latest kind of
controversy because some people like oh
there's so much hype about it and i
watched it and it was just okay blah
blah blah because everybody's saying oh
it's so mind-blowing and i'm not gonna
say i'm not coming out and saying it's
the goriest thing i've ever seen it's
not
but it's pretty [ __ ] gory you know
what i mean and it's good i really liked
it i really liked it it's kind of like i
mean it's not super original it's kind
of like
it's not a zombie movie it's an
infection movie but it's kind of like
the crazies or 28 days later or
something like that where somebody's
like a fast-acting virus that makes
people act like psychos it's that kind
of thing but um you know it's it's good
it's good
um let me see yeah get time to watch uh
blair witch 2 book of shadows i'm you
know what i like blair witch one well
blair wish too is completely different
though it's not found footage okay um
the thing about it
maybe this is a controversial opinion
and i haven't seen it in a long time so
don't hate
the first time that i saw blair witch 2
i actually quite i really liked it
and i was actually surprised when i
found out later like what a shitty
reputation it has like everybody talking
about oh it's the worst [ __ ] nobody
said it's the worst thing ever but a lot
of people are like it gets really like
negative reviews and i was like i
remember really liking it i thought it
was like pretty clever
um and i like that they
you know the first ones found footage
sort of like we're just gonna not do
found footage but they kind of made like
a meta statement about
can you believe what you see like on
videotape and it's i i don't know i just
really like the way they did it but like
i said i haven't seen it a long time so
it might suck but i remember really
liking it when i saw it the first time
interestingly too now i'm talking about
shutter uh they also added a documentary
yesterday
that's called uh the found footage
phenomenon and even though found footage
is not really my favorite sub genre um
one there have been a lot of good ones
and two the documentary was actually
really interesting
um and it sort of gave me like a new
respect for the genre i guess when they
had like a lot of directors on there
that had made them and they were kind of
like talking about
a lot of the challenges like inherent in
making them and i was kind of like oh
yeah i guess so so i was you know so it
kind of gave me like a new respect for
the genre even though like i said it's
not my favorite haunted house ones are
my favorite probably but i'll see you
know i'll watch good found footage
although i'm more a fan of like
mockumentaries which is kind of like
found footage but slightly different you
know i like mockumentaries like lake
mungo or the bay or
something like that but there's good
found footage movies and they talked
about like a bunch of one here as well
like uh
oh they talk about creep on there which
if you haven't seen that
there's a bunch of movies called that
but look for the one that has mark two
class in it
and it's a fountain footage movie i
think it's from 2016.
i can't remember but somewhere around 15
something like that there was a sequel
too and the sequel is also pretty great
they used to be on netflix but i don't
know if they're still on there anymore
but they're both good they're both good
they're super creepy
jim says hair looks awesome today thank
you yeah i told her that
yeah i was happy i just got these
yesterday in the mail like like i said i
got three of these the same style but
different colors i got a blue and a red
one and a black she's growing her hair
out
so her natural hair will be similar to
that we'll see it yeah but the thing
about it
it's not going to be this color it's
going to be black but um
but the thing about it is that my hair
you know because the underside was
shaved for a long time and then just
because i didn't even like make a
conscious decision to grow the shave
part back out i just got lazy and i
didn't cut it and then i was like oh i
guess i'm growing it back out and now
it's like too long to cut off again
so then i cut the back part of it like
shorter so it would you know all be even
quicker you could get that hair that
hair with an undercut though
you could shave yeah i could
i don't know i might i might because i
do i do like having the undercut i mean
i can undercut it all you do is ask me
well i can un undercut it too i've done
it my whole life like pretty much i mean
i did it before i did it back in the 90s
oh you did yeah okay no i did it back in
the late 80s actually
so i used to do it like by myself all
you need is a mirror
i guess it's harder to do it is but i
can do it if i have to but i was doing
it for years and you say well [ __ ] i
didn't have to do it all this time you
could have done it well i did it by
myself lots of times
but yeah so um
but yeah so the hair now is kind of like
at a [ __ ] up point because it's not
long or short the long point yeah the
long part is like this long and then
like the underneath is like this long
and then i'm trying to grow the bangs
out and the bangs are like this long
yeah so it's like three different
lengths yeah long enough so a lot of the
times i'll either pull it all back and
like just clip all the [ __ ] back or i'll
just like put a wig cap on and put a wig
over it until it all grows out to one
because a part in the middle like that
actually looks better on you than wigs
than bangs
yeah that's what that that's what we
decided right
we decided yeah it does look good i
think people it depends well
it's better like that than with bangs
it's hard for me to like get used to
because i've i've had bangs for such a
long time
that seeing myself without bangs i'm
like oh my god look how [ __ ] huge my
forehead is like it just makes your face
look thinner it just makes my forehead
look no i don't think so well you guys
could
immediate to me it makes your face look
longer i think it looks good
yeah maybe
i don't know like i said it depends on a
lot of things it depends on
what color the hair is it depends on the
makeup it depends on a lot of different
things i think it's more youthful
yeah yeah
yeah okay we'll see in that cut well
like i said i bought three wigs yeah
this same exact
style and length yeah because i did like
the the longer one that i have before
like the the ombre or whatever that's
like black and blue but it's really long
so it's like i don't mind wearing it
sometimes i'm going out or something but
it's kind of a pain because it goes like
all the way down here and it's like a
lot of hair so i was like well i want
something like that but shorter and
thinner so it's not so
bulky and heavy
so i got three of these from the same
company so eventually i mean this this
came out good so i got a red one and a
black one
and when i have more money
they had like a bunch of colors they had
like green and pink and purple and they
had like orange i like the orange one
actually so it's like they had all kind
of like fun colors i was like maybe i'll
get like a whole [ __ ] rainbow of the
[ __ ] then i could have like a matching
wig for every single yeah
outfit that i have that would be neat
you know
until my hair grows out
yeah tammy said that's how i grew my
hair long just out of laziness yeah it's
just i don't know it's man it's just
like so much maintenance that's what i
was saying before it's like i just kind
of wish
you know tom's lucky like he looks good
bald i don't
so it's like well i don't think i look
good bald i've never done that i've
never been like brave enough remember
that red vamps the mexican vampire girl
yeah she's bald
yeah she's bald she's doing nothing but
wigs
yeah i i can feel that i understand that
i understand and then when she goes bald
she only goes bald when she dresses as
the clown
because she dresses up as a clown with a
big old [ __ ] feet and [ __ ] she does
the evil clown face that's cool paints
on her head and she'll just be bald or
put a bozo thing around the side of her
it looks hilarious
and then she'll jump on a [ __ ] harley
and go to the damn you're making all
kinds of money at the we got i want to
go to the mexican goth scene
it looks good it looks great awesome it
looks [ __ ] awesome yeah i mean at
least from voltaire's going back to
their [ __ ] ass
girlfriend go down there boba and [ __ ]
down in the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
the mayan underworld the mexican [ __ ]
mexican hell it looks it's great well
like i said i just love all of that
[ __ ] day of the dead yeah like
visuals and [ __ ] like that i mean that's
they got it they're so [ __ ] cool they
got it that's like goth as [ __ ] yeah
they didn't have to
and they they
what's funny is that they mixed in like
industrial and goth
and mexican traditional mexican it
[ __ ] works man it works
yeah i love spooky as [ __ ] i love that
look it's very unique i love it very
unique yeah
but you know
i just don't think i haven't thought
about
shaving my [ __ ] head
because i have
you have to wear wigs all the time i
would yeah i mean i do have a lot of
wigs yeah but
that's the thing it's i don't know how i
would feel about it because i said well
if i shave my head then i would pretty
much have to wear wigs all the time they
get hot like every time i go out and
that would be hot and they're kind of
heavy
and depending on
because that with that black one that
danzig wig that you have that i wore the
other day i don't know if that's just
like some other size or something like
that but that gave me a head that [ __ ]
was tight yeah
uh i could shave it i could shave it
down to a good short haircut where it's
parted off to one side you have enough
hair for that
yeah it's getting to like cause my hair
like they had those in the 20s yeah like
something out of the 20s because the
thing about my hair is that it would
look really butch
that's okay it was like really i don't
mind looking butch i'm not like that's
fine i'm not bothered by that all right
but um
the thing about it is my hair is so
[ __ ]
thick yeah
and it's just the crazy thing about it
every time i wash my [ __ ] hair every
time i brush my hair
like a whole bunch of it like comes out
like i wash my hair and then i have to
like take the thing and there's like
strands just just big like [ __ ]
clumps of it and it all comes out and
every time like i brush my hair it all
comes out like not a [ __ ] ton like i
don't you know i don't have a disease or
something like that but it's like a
bunch of it comes out and yet my hair
doesn't get any thinner it's just this
big bulky and like when it like when i
wash it and i just let it dry i don't
blow dry it or anything i just kind of
let it dry naturally and it just goes
and it's just this big thick it's so
like yeah it never does what i want it
to do it's just kind of like this big i
don't even know what the [ __ ] she'll be
asking they're saying that we should do
a show but you can read it
you guys should do a show on how you
decided to start a podcast and youtube
channel i'm so fascinated by your hard
work we just talked about yes well we
can talk about that right now if you
want to yeah i mean honestly okay so
what happened was back in 2016 this is
probably why i don't even really think
that i had started because i had like
um boy thunder yeah yeah i cuz i i never
even really thought about starting a
youtube channel because i was like
nobody wants to look at my [ __ ] mug
that's for sure and um so i never really
thought about it plus i had like kind of
weird like anxiety like i didn't really
want to like
perform in front of like anybody so
there was that
but
we were at a
convention it wasn't really a convention
it was kind of like it was at um
gods and monsters that comic store yeah
and they were having a big event this
was back in summer of 2016 i think right
or sometime or spring of 2016. something
what you're talking about
yeah it was that big thing at um gods
and monsters
from there no no no uh we were there
selling books remember they had like a
horror event back in the background yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and uh so they had
like a bunch of like a bunch of florida
horror writers and comic writers and
sci-fi writers and that's you know they
had like they showed like sci-fi films
like that florida people had made and
[ __ ] like that it was really fun [ __ ]
cosplayers yeah cosplayers and stuff it
was like a little event that they had
so we were at that and we had a table
and we were selling um
books so i had like some books there
that i was selling and we met um a
horror writer who's also from florida
armand rosen rosimelia rosamilia yeah
yeah
and um we got talking to him and he was
like selling him because he's like
pretty well known so um he was selling a
bunch of books and [ __ ] like that and he
was like
he had a um
podcast network at the time like he had
a podcast and he had like
i don't know 10 or 11 like other
podcasts that were on there they weren't
all horror related but his was and then
they had some other stuff that was all
kind of like or adjacent
and
when we were there we got to talking to
him and he's like oh you know it's like
you guys
are really funny
like you go and like your rapport is
like really funny like with one another
it's like you guys should do a show
because that would be really that'd be
really funny and it's like you could um
put it on our network
which what was it called back then
project entertainment network yeah it
was a long time ago it was a long time
ago yeah this was like back in 2016.
and we were like you know we never
really thought about that he's like yeah
it helps like sell your books because
people get your name out there and your
personality and stuff like that was very
different back then yeah situation was
very different podcasts you could make
money on youtube was was it was around
but but most people didn't really know
how that how to how to do it at that
time just a different time
yeah that's true this is just how we
started we started on
podcasts on a podcast network
which it was fun we were getting a lot
of [ __ ]
downloads off of that but no interaction
they never contacted us no one ever
talked to us we got pulled into youtube
youtube was instant gratification
yeah because at first we basically just
recorded the audio right
for whatever because we started out
doing because they didn't have streaming
not really i mean not to any great
extent and like i had really shitty
equipment so we wouldn't have been able
to stream back then even if they had it
so there was that but we just started
out doing audio so i would send him the
audio files like once a week and he
would put the show up and then um i
would just take the audio file and then
i would just do like a slideshow like
for whatever we were talking about now
we would usually just start talking
about like our first couple shows we did
the first show we did was about the
shining and the entity then we did one
about the satanic panic and then we did
like a lot of paranormal type shows
because that's kind of like the books i
was writing at the time
and you know just [ __ ] like that
and
uh it seemed like we got a lot of uh you
know kind of feedback for it and [ __ ]
like that but as the show went on
we stored it we sort of started like
expanding
where people like oh you should do movie
reviews and i'm really into horror
movies and you know so i was like okay
well we'll add a movie review so then we
just started we did a one episode a week
which we tried to keep down to an hour
because that's kind of what the podcast
thing was it's like yeah they're most of
the shows were about an hour so we tried
which is crazy now because now we go on
for like three or four yeah like now we
go up for three hours and i'm like oh
it's not long enough this is like we go
on for like three four five six hours
yeah and i see i i'm
i'm of the philosophy that it shouldn't
go over three hours
um i actually wouldn't want it to go
over two but we've had so many people in
the comments going no no no i'm at work
and the [ __ ] i need you guys to talk
to me as long as possible so my work day
goes by faster there was also we had
truckers to go yeah i'm listening to you
in this [ __ ] long haul and [ __ ]
you know no long show
so we're
we're helping people kill time
yeah and you know i understand it
because i do the same thing i listen to
podcasts not podcasts but i listen to
youtube shows i listen to people on
rumble and bit shoot you know i got
creators on all of that so i understand
the scene because i'm a consumer
and i go back i can watch some of our
shows and [ __ ] love them i'm like man
i can't believe that's me i can't
believe i said this [ __ ] you know
it is funny some of the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
you know it's funny i never go back and
listen to them i got back and listen
that was good on that day because i'm
like because i'm like holy crap i don't
want to know if i said some dumb [ __ ]
back there because i'll just like cringe
at myself
i still have like yeah i have like
issues about i'm not as bad as i used to
be but i absolutely will not get back
i've gone back and checked them and
[ __ ]
said that was a bad show man [ __ ] let
me go back and see how bad that was and
then we're like oh i wasn't that bad
i kind of feel like that's probably what
because a lot of times i don't feel this
all the time and like i said it's better
than it used to be because we've been
doing this for so long so i don't have
like a complex about it like i used to
but for a long time
uh we would do the shows
and then
even like whether they were recorded or
live or whatever and then like i would
go back and go man that sucked up was
like so bad yeah it's like i [ __ ] this
up and i [ __ ] that up and we went off
on all these tangents and it's like it's
i didn't get into all the stuff and i
didn't
talk about like the stuff i wanted to
talk about like the way i want to talk
about i miss this and i miss that and so
i'm always like you know you know how it
is so i was always kind of like that but
then like sometimes
um other people would like message me
about it and be like man that [ __ ] was
so awesome and stuff i'm like okay well
maybe it wasn't as bad as i thought but
it's like i don't know i'm still like
afraid to go back to the show shelby who
asked this question she's got her own
channel look that's her
look look at
20
so she's oh cool 27 subscribers so you
got a new channel huh shelby nice okay
that's cool actually no it's not new a
year ago
shelby said uh lol when i downloaded i
remember looking you guys up trying to
see a face to the voice yeah for a long
time i was kind of like it was much
easier just to record the audio because
you know it's like
we didn't have to like
look good or dress up or not like she
was back in those days yeah yeah you've
been listening for a long time shelby
yeah that's a long time yeah because
[ __ ] when did we start doing video i
don't even remember video was about four
or five years ago in five years
something like that like i just i know
we started live streaming
six we started live streaming at around
episode 200 because i remember everybody
kept asking oh you should live stream oh
you should live stream um and then i
said oh episode 200 is coming up and so
let's do live stream for that
and when we did because i was like
freaking out i was like oh my god
because before everything was recorded
and i was like yeah if we [ __ ] up i
could fix it
and i was like oh my god now we're just
gonna be like out there and it's gonna
be live and it's like if we [ __ ] up i
can't like do anything about it and it's
like it was really stressing me out
but when we did
show 200 live i was like oh
this is funner well because it was
better because
one you get like real-time interaction
and you could just kind of like hang and
chill and it was just kind of like fun
and i didn't really have to like edit it
afterward because editing like the [ __ ]
takes a really long time i still do some
we still do some recorded stuff like you
do the movie watch we do the movie
retrospectives i do like a book review
and a couple movie reviews a week that i
record and edit but i don't really like
take a lot out the only [ __ ] i take out
of you know my videos or our videos is
if i forget somebody's name or if i have
to look something up or if i'm just
sitting there going um you know like
i'll take that out but other than that i
don't really take anything out unless i
really [ __ ] something james said if we
watch the videos from how tom looks no
one would ever want to watch
yeah
mr 88 says i have long hair too it looks
like a bunch of hair comes out when you
comb it but it's really only normal hair
shedding like 10 to 30 strands
it just looks like a lot because it's
long i know but
holy [ __ ] my my shower drain doesn't
want to hear that because i gotta pour a
[ __ ] drano down that [ __ ] all the
time all the [ __ ] hair coming out
i have thought about shaving my head
bald i was like it would make him
wearing wigs a lot easier but the thing
about it
i don't know this is kind of like the
same [ __ ] i don't know maybe like a
bigger
uh what's the word i'm looking for like
a more you know egregious example of
like remember when i first shaved my
eyebrows off yeah
and remember like the
existential crisis i had because of that
yeah um
you were like what it's fine you can
just like draw them on i was like yeah
but now if i want to just go to the
[ __ ] 7-eleven without putting on all
the makeup which is a pain in the ass
now i have to like draw eyebrows on or
everybody look at me like i'm a [ __ ]
alien yeah they wouldn't dude
yeah you can go over that eyebrows
nobody would notice
probably not no
i kind of have a weird thing where it's
like i feel like
when i shave my hair half the time i
shave my eyebrows too i'll just put a
number one on number one [ __ ]
guard on the clippers and just like go
over
because that's why the old men got those
[ __ ] huge brushy album they don't
[ __ ] cut their goddamn eyebrows man i
[ __ ] [ __ ] shave that [ __ ] off you
know what the other day i was thinking i
was like you know what i think i'm going
to grow my eyebrows back because i have
like some eyebrow templates
like that are supposed to like help you
like [ __ ] you know pluck them and
stuff pluck them so chickens no you know
what i mean
like shape your eyebrows
so i was like maybe i'll grow my
eyebrows back
uh so i let them grow for like two or
three days and i was like no [ __ ] it
i just shaved him back
i mean it's a pain in the ass drawing
them on too
but
it's more of a pain to [ __ ] pluck
them to
shape them and pluck them because you
have to do that [ __ ] like all the time
because i don't know if you guys know
because you've never probably seen my
real eyebrows but my eyebrows are like
wolfman jack eyebrows if you guys are
everybody's old enough to remember that
i have like big [ __ ] black
bushy eyebrows like brook shields in the
70s eyebrows i'm talking they're not
that bad
they are they're like they're big
they're big but they're not that they're
not as big as brook shields they're all
over the place and it's just like ugh
and i just had like i think i was the
one that suggested it but you were going
down that path anyway
i mean my first wife she she never had
eyebrows she had them
she had them and uh for what she said
she had them when she was a kid and then
she was just like why have those
because everything she does this pain is
drawn on anyway
and she didn't draw she wouldn't always
draw them on you know like well i got to
go to the store and
nah she didn't give a [ __ ]
she'd just go down without eyebrows i'm
actually proud of myself because i went
to dollar general the other day
because i had to get some treats for
pookie or whatever and i said you know
what it's my day off cause i wasn't
streaming and i wasn't recording
anything and i don't put makeup on on
those days because [ __ ] it it takes too
long
um and i was like but i have to go to
dollar general i'm like [ __ ] it i'm not
putting a [ __ ] full face of makeup on
just to get a dollar general down the
[ __ ] street yeah so i went there with
no makeup on and i was just gonna like
it was really liberating and i was like
wow nobody stared at me even though i
didn't have any even though i didn't
have any eyebrows and looked like an
ogre probably no
they're not looking at you very closely
maybe i've i i don't know i have i've
always had like this weird
i don't know if it's like body
dysmorphia or something like that but i
always like feel like i look like
an ogre or i feel or i look like a freak
or something like that no you know what
i mean no you look pretty normal
that's when you're decked out you look
great so but you just walk around just
looking normal like anybody else okay
no it's it's in your mind yeah i know
but it's hard to get over it's hard to
get over
um mr88 says you two have great couple
rapport
i guess he says report but i guess even
he's rapport yeah i will not say jen's
patience is a major factor man shut the
[ __ ] up but it might be a lot of [ __ ]
everybody's gonna try oh it totally
everybody's trying it totally is
nobody's blaming you for showing look at
you getting all defenses
okay he's getting all defensive i'm
gonna make another drink
he's getting all defensive
i am very i am very patient i am ready
i mean i you know i i but
i have my limits too just gonna say
tammy said yeah i shed so much hair i
have to clean my vacuum brush out every
other day but still a head full of hair
yeah i don't understand
i don't know like sometimes i brush my
hair and i'm like how is there still
hair in my head i don't understand like
how
and there's so much of it and like i
said we live in florida and it's hot and
it's just kind of like
i run by something like
that it's like there's so much of it and
i was like god i wish i could just
[ __ ] shave it
i just feel like if i shaved it all off
then my head would just look like a big
[ __ ] giant bowling ball
and i'm just
and there's no going back from it that's
what i'm scared of like the eyebrows
that's not that big a deal like yeah i
can just like [ __ ] draw them on like
with eyeliner or whatever but
if i shave my whole head
and then i decide i don't like it then
i'm like oh i'm stuck wearing wigs for
like a really long time until the [ __ ]
grows back out you know
uh you know it's so it's it's a whole
thing but i have been like thinking
about it especially because i have so
many wigs now
that
i don't know and especially because my
hair now like looks so stupid because of
like the cut because it's so like
transitional
and i'm just kind of like god i can't
get it to do anything
good
it is
if we got if you guys lose this it's not
it's not our connection it's the storm
yeah it's like it's not as bad as it was
earlier but i can still hear it this is
like some [ __ ] out of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
the fog
that john carpenter's the fog oh [ __ ]
goes
ghost pirates are kind of ghost pirates
will be here
adrian i see jenny your skin is awesome
what is your routine
you know what i don't really have a
routine all i do
is
you know wash my face just with regular
ass soap
or
whatever like cleanser i get with my
ipsy thing that smells good like my ipsy
subscription
and uh then i slap just regular ass
cheap jergens lotion on it she's got
great skin that's all i do
i don't put any special [ __ ] on it it's
just regular soap and cheap ass lotion
that i got at the dollar store she got
skip she's got the skin of a [ __ ]
somebody in her 20s
she's pushing 50.
and i don't know why that is like i
don't do anything special to it i don't
like my mom
is [ __ ] close to 70 right she's like
close to 7. she's 60 well she's 18 years
older than me yeah so she's 67 68. she
looks she looks pretty young she looks
like piazza dora
costing piezadora and [ __ ] uh
and my mom like looks i mean she looks
way younger than her age she's like i
said she's probably 67 68 but she looks
way younger than that yeah um
and she got carded
at bars and stuff like that into her
well into her 40s
yeah and 50s so
i think a lot of it is probably just
like i just got lucky
genetically like in some ways i didn't
because she won't work out with me i
also got she'll work out on her own but
she won't work out with me ain't that
some [ __ ] i said come on jan let's go
why is this lift why is that weird
because you know it's good to train you
know what i mean it's [ __ ] it's good
bonding i've been training you know i
train with you but
because she doesn't want me to see her
going
i'm not making fun of me i'm not that
kind of [ __ ] i don't like doing
[ __ ] in front of other people it's
ridiculous people
because she's got good genetics man
she's been on this [ __ ] thing right
here man her legs are getting [ __ ]
nice all right but she needs to [ __ ]
do some [ __ ] squats and some [ __ ]
curls even though your arms are your
arms are coming in but
it's like
it's not high enough impact need to come
work with me and then core training
puts you on i see i'm doing dead lifts
and [ __ ] weighted um sit-ups right
now put a 50-pound weight on do sit-ups
i can only do 15 percent
and my [ __ ] i'm getting some v taper
it's starting to come in now i got the
chemistry right and everything
a couple months i'm gonna [ __ ] six
i'm gonna be [ __ ] i'm probably at
like 15
maybe 16 body fat i'm gonna try to get
this [ __ ] the sub
sub 15 percent i'm gonna get down to
like [ __ ] 12 10 12. i i'm gonna be
like male fitness
model level
pride another [ __ ] six months
we'll see we'll see
but yeah i'm just saying like i don't
need to go on this journey with me jan
you're going to go on this journey with
me and pookie can be with us too then
pookie can watch look see look at
cookies like i'm not going to get
somebody no cookie will never work out
yeah just little drumsticks just leave
them drumsticks on
little gray wiener dog and stop calling
you're a wiener cat come here wiener cat
but yeah i'm just saying i don't really
i don't do anything i don't have any
like
special skin stuff or anything like
every now and then like i said i have an
ipsy subscription which if you don't
know is like that little subscription
box where i think it's 10 bucks a month
or something like that and they send you
like a little bag that has all these
like cool like makeup samples in it
so sometimes they'll send like a cool
skin cleanser that smells like
watermelon and i'm like ooh and i'll use
that for a little while or sometimes
they send like little masks and i'll use
those like maybe once every couple
months when i remember that i have them
but most of the time i just wash my face
with normal ass soap
and put lotion on it and like i said the
lotion that i like is that cheap ass
jergens is it jerkins i think it's
jurgen's like their cherry almond their
original cherry almond i just really
like that so i get that from amazon like
everything i just put that on my face
like
you use botox no she doesn't use botox
no i don't use i don't use anything no
and she always looked like that
she has done
a little bit of hormone replacement
therapy
and she's done a couple little small
cycles
of wind straw and anavar
but that didn't change her face or her
skin tone okay one thing that changed is
that uh
her legs recomped a bit where she got
more muscle definition a little smaller
um
calf ankle areas her legs got better
look good but she won't show them off
because she
i don't know why that says babe put some
put some [ __ ] stockings on put that
[ __ ] little short dress on let's go
out and listen and she's not out yet
because show the legs off you got good
legs
but she's used to [ __ ]
long skirts and pants and stuff
but
she's just gonna take her time to adapt
and then
well i don't i don't think you
understand like the impact that it has
on your entire life when you're a girl
and you're like through your entire
childhood and teenage years you look
like kind of like a chubby like chunky
yeah you don't really look like but
that's what i mean but
because you because i grew up like that
i still like see myself like that and i
know i don't look like that anymore but
she'll layer clothes on
to hide behind him and
i guess because she thinks she's fat she
gets bigger which he like like no no no
no take all that off the less clothes
you have the [ __ ] smaller you look
and the better you look
you're at that point you've been at that
point matter of fact when we put five
six years ago when we first started
[ __ ] hanging out and dating each
other this is before
when we started dating each other
because we knew each other before that
was more like 11 years more like a
11 years tom has no sense of time yeah
about 11 years now
yeah uh you were already far beyond all
that
you know kind of like chunky girl [ __ ]
well she was a little she was a little
chunky when i met her
she was married at the time
after she divorced she [ __ ] got in
good shape i got really i actually got
too skinny yes like afterwards
she got real thin it didn't it didn't
look that good she's not really
built for that her
jenny has a medium frame skeleton she's
supposed to be thick thick and muscular
booty and good legs i mean i went down
to she got too light right yeah i went
down like really good yeah i got down to
a point where like i was excited because
i was like whoo look it's i only weigh
108 oh [ __ ] let me go wait it's
reconnecting
oh you know what though it's like the
light's still green
okay hold on okay it says it reconnected
it says it reconnected hopefully we
didn't get too much like i said it's
storming outside so
hopefully
hopefully hopefully hopefully
js says i've lost 100 pounds and the
body bdd is real i totally get it yeah
it's the thing about it is that
um
yeah i mean i my mom and all of the
women on her side of the family because
she has like a bunch of sisters
they're all kind of like built the same
as me we're all uh pretty short like i'm
only about five to three
um they're all about five to three five
foot four and they're always they're all
kind of like thick they have like short
arms short legs
um you know thick ankles
big thighs uh so all of the women are
kind of built like that which you know i
i never really wanted to be built like
that but you know you don't ask for your
genetics so there's that
and so i always kind of wanted to like
look different and it was always like
frustrating that i didn't
so i was skinny when i was a kid
once i hit puberty i just porked right
out
like once i was 11 or 12 years old like
i you know i went through puberty like i
said and just like started getting
heavier and heavier heavier
and then when i was in my 20s uh i got
married and then i started working out
like playing soccer and stuff like that
so i lost some weight then
and looked pretty good for a while but
then like as time went on i started
gaining weight again and gaining weight
again but then like i got divorced and
then i dropped
almost 100 pounds
um but i got like too thin and i started
having like health problems where
i kept like fainting and like i had to
go to the doctor i had to go to the
cardiologist because they thought it
like was having like weird heartbeats
because you lost weight though yeah
that's why i mean they they thought that
that's probably what it was they're like
look your body remember because i lost
like 90 like 80 90 pounds in like five
months or like some really short time
period i didn't recognize her when i saw
her yeah and um
my heart was just kind of like what i
know
some people didn't even know who she was
yeah
back at the club they were like you
don't know who that is no no that's
because i looked completely just like
and then i was trying to explain to them
who that was
says you remember the guy and the girl
oh that's her no yeah that's her
she looks totally different
yeah it did look totally different yeah
so i mean i've gained some weight back
since then
um
but like i said i was probably too thin
before i kind of feel like i
you were meant
on your frame and your scale to to be
about 135 pounds that's my ideal weight
135 pounds of muscular
in other words muscle
fat but muscle also
and uh
easy to get because like i said i went
down to 118 and i looked
too about two
too skinny i looked like
weird yeah you had 135 is i kind of feel
like that's where i look
right good like i look healthy and i
look yeah
not fat and you know right i put you in
about a 135 that's like yeah that's
usually my goal muscular 135 and [ __ ]
you'd look great
you're not far from that
i have no idea whatever you can get to
that one i could get you to that
in three or four months if you train
with me but you have to [ __ ] just
it's so easy twice a week silly it's so
easy fun
and and you see i think part of it the
reason why jenny is scared of it because
she hears me in there going
but i'm doing like
i'm not scared of it because i'm going i
just don't want to do it i'm going and
he won't listen i'm going like 220
15 rep reps and like yeah because his
gym is right next to my office that's
right there right so i'm at a point
where i need a lot of weight so
sometimes i'm in here reading a book and
i'll hear
and i'm just like god damn it like the
[ __ ] hulk in there
and uh but the thing is that is that is
that female routines are do not require
that much weight it's a lot less weight
so it's not as hard on you
i think i made a mistake a couple times
when i was trying to train you earlier
is that i started you off on too much
weight too soon it's yeah i'd have to
work you up to it start with kind of
light weights
and um
i can get everything we need for your
age and my age to [ __ ] put the body
in the right [ __ ] state of being to
where you get a lot for a lot of return
quickly
and in a couple months now we
had it totally rebuild in a couple
months three four months and then
four weeks into it three weeks into it
you already see a visible difference
mr88 says modesty is not an attribute i
would have attributed to jen oh no jen's
[ __ ] you don't uh nobody don't know
her
[Laughter]
that that might be my defining
characteristic
she's
self-defeating well like i said
i grow you know what this is how this is
how [ __ ] up this is and i was just
thinking about this the other day
i said the the way i grew up
and i wasn't even like heavy until i was
a teenager but because when i was a kid
i was always real shy and real bookish
and stuff like that so people kind of
like made fun of me and like bullied me
a little bit
um
so there was that so even to this day
i have a thing where if somebody
compliments me i think they're making
fun of me
because a lot of times when i was in
junior high and stuff like that people
were
they were making fun of me yeah those
days have been long gone but like i said
you that's still like it hangs around
yeah so i'm always kind of like so i'm
one of those people that's just kind of
like
um
you know
i don't know it's just and i kind of
feel like too people think that i'm
maybe like aloof or
like i'm snotty or something like that
and like when you remember like imani
said that to us one time like she said i
thought you guys were just like too cool
to like talk to him but it was like it's
not that i feel like i stay over here in
the corner like you know smoking a
cigarette i don't do that anymore but
when i used to i just stay over here
because i feel like nobody wants to talk
to me it's like who the hell wants to
like i don't want to go and like
interrupt other people's
night or their anything like that like
why would they want to talk to me so
it's not snotty i'm just not
i understand what amani's talking about
but i never really saw it that way yeah
because
once me and jen started to hang out we
were actually a pretty good team because
we kind of had skills that
complemented each other because they cut
we covered each other's blind spots
i have i have a [ __ ] i'm very um
positive and aggressive with really good
sales techniques
and really good human engineering skills
and the ability to size well he's
outgoing and confident
and i'm not right
and because i was kind of had a kind of
a [ __ ] i'm a fighter and literally a
fighter
but i'm also a great salesman and i am a
great salesman i was winning [ __ ]
competitions on my sales teams and [ __ ]
and i was a good sales manager i could
[ __ ] train other people on how to
sell because of that
jenny allowed me to have something to
sell
which i liked that even though i was
retired
but we were friends and [ __ ] we
started a little kind of business
together and it was it was involved in
the scene and [ __ ] that we liked so it
all kind of came
organically none of this was to a plan
it was
day by day seeing an opportunity and all
of oh that's no problem and this and it
and and i never really realized that
jenny lacked confidence
i'm good at faking it yeah it was just
like after you have to learn to fake it
yeah afterwards i was like but it is
based on things that she was saying i
was like oh yeah that would have
impressed me years ago before you know i
mean had i seen this from the outside
but it's just because we'd go to those
[ __ ]
we'd go to uh like comic-con and i'd
sell every copy we had
you know i'd sell them all
because if i'm talking to you then i'm
not gonna let you go away and we're
gonna talk and then i'm gonna introduce
you to jenny we're gonna hang out and
then i'm gonna say uh here once you go
ahead and will you let's let's get a
signed copy of jenny's new book and they
go yeah
let's take a picture together
and you know sell books that way i
wasn't shoving books down people's
throats
it was social
it was talking to people
you know
getting to know people
the customer
you know finding out what they liked
and then
giving them a book
and then saying contact us online and
[ __ ] some of them did
some left reviews and everything you
know
and so it's not
it's not inauthentic
you're just doing it from the heart
you know it just happens
and i think the people who are kind of
i don't want to say sheltered but people
who aren't really um
ready for like uh the sales experience
and because you know i've been doing
direct sales once i got out of the army
you know i did direct sales for [ __ ]
years i i loved it
it it seems unnatural i think from the
point of view of another but to me it's
very natural
it's just natural to sell things well
yeah i mean people people's
personalities and proclivities are
really different i'm i mean ever since i
was a kid
i don't really like people
um i don't really like it's it's not
like individual people it's just like i
don't
being around people is um exhausting for
me
um having to
kind of project a kind of like social
kind of thing it's very exhausting for
me because i'm very introverted so you
know i just i don't mind like spending
time with people but it just makes me
like really really tired and it really
really like stresses me out yeah so
i don't enjoy it um honestly it's like
if i could live just like
bye bye bye see you later
if i could live just like writing books
and designing games and stuff like that
and people just buy them without me
having to like talk to anybody ever like
in person i don't mind doing this
but
because i'm just you know sitting in the
office and talking to you guys and stuff
like that but
um
having to go to like conventions and
stuff like that i was glad that he was
there because i'm just kind of like
if it was just me i would just sit there
and be like i wouldn't even like talk to
people because it was adriana says
something to you
um
jenny i totally get you i'm curvy and
short lost and gained weight and bookish
and bullied in high school and people
think i'm aloof all the time yeah you
just get to a point where and it's not
that like i'm not snotty i don't think
i'm better than anybody or nothing like
that it's actually the opposite
i actually think why would that person
like why would they want to talk to me
like why would i go over there and like
interrupt whatever conversation they're
having even people i know like friends
and stuff like that so it's like
sometimes this is [ __ ] up but like
sometimes we'll go to mannequins or
something like that and
tom will go over and talk to like some
people that we know and i'm just like
i'm just gonna stay over here because
like i feel like why do they want to
talk to me and i can't hear what they're
saying anyway because i'm definite but
you know so there's that as well so
hopefully that answered your question
and says you don't have anything where
if you
excuse me adriana anything to worry
about being short and curvy you got
pictures right there your cutie pie
pewdiepie
well
i kind of feel like well the thing about
it is that it sucks because
particularly if you're a woman it's like
so much is tied up in what you look like
like so much your value is tied up on
what you look like so
i kind of feel like every woman i know
as beautiful as they are
always has
they're like well there's this and
there's that they always like are like
there's something wrong with me they
always wish there was something if their
hair is curly they wish it was straight
if their you know nose is small they
wish it was big it's like or opposite
so it's just kind of like
you're always i don't know i just feel
like there's this whole cultural thing
where
she's laying there like this like with
her little back legs sticking out her
little belly like what
here's the thing about women and looks
do matter
that's what i mean they did
all right but they matter on men too
um
and i saw it happen with my first wife i
saw it happen with jen
you take a good-looking girl and she
gets implants all of a sudden she's even
more good-looking the way people treat
him they even treat him even better
people treated me pretty well i started
to get jacked it's even more so and you
know what it was the it's the guys the
guys treat you better
and with the with women and the implants
women treat them better
it's it's weird it's like you get more
respect from your own gender
but um
the thing is
the problem with women is i'm gonna tell
women in general this is yeah looks
matter they do
but where women go wrong is that they
assume that all men like the same thing
or like the same things in the same ways
in other words you see a hundred pound
[ __ ] 19 year old girl
and [ __ ] in some fashion
ad
and their that company is trying to make
you think that that's what guys are
looking for
guys might like that but there's a lot
of other things that guys like too it's
not just one flavor it's baskin robbins
it's 51 flavors
baskin robbins is thirty one dirty one
flavor sorry i was just
well actually baskin robbins is 31 30.
i'm gonna say 51 or it used to be
there's even but they might have more
flavor here's the [ __ ] thing i don't
know is that um
no they got short and curvy women that
are just look [ __ ] fantastic because
that they were born to look like that
but they also
[ __ ] had the right body composition
to make that look good they had the
muscle and the fat and the [ __ ] and
the fashion
and everything all working together they
got some
stocky little curvy girls that are just
killing it on instagram
all right
and it's because guys aren't really
limited to one type of beauty there they
most guys like a variety
you just have to
take what it is that you were given
and hone that
into the best version of what you were
given you know what i mean
um pretty much all of those body styles
can be made attractive skinny can be
made attractive
um like uh our
our little friend
um
sonia she weighed nothing like 90 pounds
and she looked great
i couldn't picture her not skinny
but i couldn't picture jenny wayne at
night looking and
being at 90 pounds she looked terrible
it's the [ __ ] well i looked kind of
terrible at 180
i mean not terrible but i looked kind of
ill yeah
it was
she was uh she was an in she was a uh
an ectomorph you know she was born to be
little and skinny you know
and some women are just tall
you know and uh tall and big with big
old feet and [ __ ] you know what i mean
they're just [ __ ] six foot two big
old [ __ ] tall women and unfortunately
you know they can't
get dates they're so [ __ ] big but
they they look good you know
[ __ ]
but that's just a different type you
know um i've heard that really the worst
a woman the worst hand a woman could be
dealt dealt is to be born above six feet
tall they said that that's yeah that's
the worst well
i knew um i i knew a couple girls that i
was uh friends with in high school that
were really tall
and yeah they had them and they oh they
had a hell of a time yeah and they're
not ugly it's just that guys run from
that because they just don't want to
date a taller woman you know
so
and guys who are six foot two are dating
[ __ ]
girls that are [ __ ] five six
you know
so
you know a tall woman is in a short is
in a bad spot they even have it worse
than short men when it comes to date
selection poor things i yeah i kind of
feel like they probably do
i'm short i'm five six
and i [ __ ]
think he's never been in trouble no
trouble no matter of fact uh a a girl
who was over six feet tall that would be
easy like taking candy from a baby
because i i know the the trouble that
she's in yeah
it's like look i i curse my genetics
sometimes too but
i don't actually i don't mind being
short i don't i don't care about being
short that's fine um would i trade like
being the way i am nowadays for being
like over six feet tall no way no way
like as a woman
no
be the worst yeah i think that would be
worse yeah and what's sad is that
they're like big old bridget nielsen
[ __ ] they're pretty they're
just [ __ ] tall they're just so well
and i think that sadly a lot of dudes
are intimidated they're like intimidated
they're intimidated they don't want to
look short next to her i look short next
to anybody
[Laughter]
he looks short next to me if i wear a
black before the platform right yeah i
look sure and i'm like three inches
shorter than you
but sometimes i wear platform boots and
he doesn't so then i'll be well i don't
usually look taller than you all right
sometimes we'll wear
together so it just kind of nobody
notices yeah but sometimes i wear
platforms and i'm just like the same
height as you or maybe an inch taller
but the weird thing about it is like and
i didn't even mean for this to happen
but my first husband was actually like a
foot taller than me
and then
before i started dating you like the guy
i was dating was actually six foot five
so he was like way bigger than me so and
i was actually like quite skinny at that
point because that was like at the point
where i was at my lightest and i'm only
five foot three that dude could carry me
around like a backpack
i mean he was like [ __ ] giant you
know what i mean so there was something
kind of weird about that i don't know
why i ended up like i didn't even like
do it on purpose because like i said i
met that guy online i didn't know he was
six foot five until i met him a person
so i just liked him online that's how
that worked out but so i didn't like
mean to pick because i know like some
dudes are like oh you have to be tall
and blah blah that's that's not true i
ended up with tall dudes but it was
completely accidental i didn't go out
seeking tall dudes i don't give a [ __ ]
about dudes heights or anything like
that um it just happened you know
so there's that it's all good adriana
man don't worry about that [ __ ] [ __ ]
go on you can go on instagram
and you could what what what happened
she's calling you can go on instagram
and you can see famous instagram girls
of about every possible
body type that have turned that in to
success
now it doesn't mean you can sit around
[ __ ] pork out and [ __ ] you know i
mean no that's
i'm just talking about
the skeleton types that are out there
[ __ ] all of them can be made
attractive and they got girls that are
[ __ ] making money on it
short and thick tall skinny little and
skinny [ __ ]
big boobs no boobs just [ __ ]
everything everything can be
adapted to become attractive to at least
some market of god
but
that's only if you want that some some
women just don't give a [ __ ]
some women are over the hill well like i
said i think the problem is and i think
i had this problem too so i can't be the
only one
but i think the problem is that
as i said because women a lot of their
value is tied up in what they look like
um i think you kind of have the weird
like low-key message
that
because that's what makes you valuable
then you have to be attractive to
everyone
and so that really like [ __ ] with you
over time because it took me a really
long time probably until i was my 20s or
30s to realize there's a market that
there's
that that's not just like one thing
that's attractive to everybody
i kind of was approaching it as well i
don't fit like the standard ideal that's
in the media all the time or that guys
seem to like
but
you have to it's like a lot more nuanced
than that there's like a lot of
different well reach what read what
grampner said about when he went to
thailand
when grandpa went to thailand
yeah can i it makes me laugh that you
still refer to yourself in the third
person that makes me laugh every single
time i went to high school with grandpa
he's a cop all the bar girls were 100
pounds with big boobs and long black
hair and after a while grampa found them
boring and common because that becomes
generic yeah
and uh a lot of the fashion models that
are making all this [ __ ] money or
whatever the one they're generic that's
just like a no not too hot if you look
at me at porn that's [ __ ] directed
directly at men that's not who you see
it
you're seeing a wide variety it's all
hot
but each look has been kind of
weaponized
and that's what we've been talking about
before is that i think that's where
confidence comes in you just kind of
have to like
find out what your thing is like what is
your what are your greatest like
attributes yeah and you weaponize them
and just like yeah just enhance those
yeah you know what i mean because
everybody has something good about them
everybody has like flaws obviously even
the most perfect person but you just
have to minimize that [ __ ] and maximize
you know what
you know
the best things about you yeah now
that's if you're young and you're in the
game
me and jenny are i'm in my i'm in my 50s
jenny's coming into her 50s we're still
in the game
but that's you know what i mean we're
we're both been working we're both in
good shape [ __ ] we still have a lot
of friends to go to the club some people
are just not really in the game anymore
and that's just they're in their own
arena
you know and if you think that it's only
women are being judged by their looks no
men are being judged by their looks too
it's just it's not so much in the
forefront and dudes aren't compliment
they're not complaining about it as much
if you're an ol if you're an old man a
short little old man when people see you
you're a short little old man
that's how they see you
you know what i mean and you're going to
fall in that
you know
those guys are not desirable
for sexual purposes well not among young
women not among young women so that i
mean because obviously young women
aren't going to go after like they're
going to go after somebody their own age
right well actually older women are not
interested in those dudes because older
people are not really interested in each
other
well yeah but that's yeah and that's
nothing to do with like what they look
like that's just that no that is what
they well yeah but i'm just saying that
like in general like older people are
kind of just like not as you take that
old man and you turn him into something
and then all of a sudden he's
interesting again i'm gonna tell you one
of the over that [ __ ] and i've said this
before already so people know i'm not
pulling this out of my ass up at that
biker bar
one of the most interesting couples i
ran into
was a tattoo artist from out of town
here he was up here for a bike a week
he's about 35.
his girlfriend was like 72
and she was a hottie
she didn't look like an average 72
though
two though she looked like a porn star
she was about the size of kaylee
all right little
thin she had big old implants
and a long white hair with a bunch of
braids and then she had [ __ ] like
hair
pieces in there and buns and [ __ ] and
dressed up in her little biker outfit
and she was [ __ ] the sexy 70 year old
that
scammed a 30-something year old dude
so she didn't scam him well you know i
don't know she earned that [ __ ]
she was robbing i mean hopefully
she was a little bitty thing she was
cute as [ __ ]
and um
she had a couple facelifts and and she
was probably on some
some stuff you know probably on hrt
but she was thin and
body a body uh about like sonia
but with uh bigger implants
biker style all right
and long white hair with braids in it
and some of it was extensions and
everything she looked [ __ ] great and
uh i said man she looks like a porn star
because he's like and he was like yeah
she does
and that was her boyfriend so
it's
people do treat you how you look
70 something years old looking like that
yeah that's how i mean people do treat
you better
you look better and it's it's honestly
doesn't even have to do yeah obviously
if you're like naturally attractive or
whatever yeah you're gonna get treated
better but people treat you better in
general if you look like you put an
effort into your appearance more than
right i mean if you just look like a bum
yeah then obviously everyone's going to
treat you like yeah and and it's it was
amusing you know what i mean she was
cool and
feminine and
fun and
look like something out of them you know
what she looked like something about a
damn lord of the rings you know what i
mean or something you know
it didn't look real but she was see
that's red see that's kind of what i
wanted like when i get old like when i
get old lady i'm gonna grow like i'm
gonna have long white hair i'm gonna
look like a witch
like a sexy witch yeah yeah and she
that's what i'm gonna aspire to and he's
like
35 36
and uh
and
in biker lingos i was like so is that
your old lady and she goes yeah that's
my old lady that [ __ ] snickered and i
just and i was like she's [ __ ] she's
like yeah she's cute and she says yeah
yeah and [ __ ] you know and and we
were just brewing out over that yeah she
looks [ __ ] great growing out over
here we were growing out over she looks
great but like i said
that didn't come for free
she worked and she did what she had to
do
and she did invest in her looks and
she probably was a model at one point
but she looked great looked great
so peter says i've been with the same
woman since 1988 so i'm incapable of
relating to the world of attempting to
secure a worthwhile partner
yeah i mean yeah it's a different world
you're not in the game and then says
later i it was my wife's heart that
attracted me i was a drummer in a heavy
metal bar bands and accustomed to party
girls my wife on the other hand was not
from that world
yeah i mean i kind of feel like as much
as we talk about yes appearances do
matter um you know anybody that says
otherwise
you know that's not true appearances do
matter but
appearances only matter
up to a point
um
you know you can be the hottest
[ __ ] in the world but if i talk
to you for 10 minutes and you seem like
a douchebag
then
you're not gonna seem all that
attractive anymore so you really do have
to have
yeah i mean somebody that's really
attractive might like draw your
attention sure but
you have to have something to back that
up um you know and honestly sometimes i
don't you know i can't speak for tom
here but i'm just saying that even
somebody that
isn't like a [ __ ] showstopper like
walking into the place like looks wise
if i talk to them for a little while and
they seem like super awesome
then they're gonna become like a lot
more attractive to me whereas like i
said if somebody that's like super super
attractive that is a showstopper and
they walk in but i talk to them and
they're just like a dick i'm just kind
of like yeah you seem kind of like ugly
to me now so
so
that's the only thing that it's
important for it's just like a first
impression is a first impression uh you
have you really have to have something
to back all that up or it just doesn't
work out you know
at least not long term maybe some people
can put up with that kind of [ __ ] longer
than i can't you know what i mean i
can't
like if there was somebody that i
thought was attractive like at a bar or
something like that if i was single and
like i started talking to them and like
within five minutes they were just kind
of like said some
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'd just be like bye
you know what i mean i don't give a [ __ ]
how hot you were
he's like you're [ __ ] annoying me so
bye
uh but yeah so um wait i saw a comment
earlier
[Music]
that i wanted to
answer sesame says i honestly don't know
any woman that's happy with how they
look i don't either i don't either and i
know it's like that's so shitty and it's
like i don't really know
what is that what can and honestly i'm
like that too
everybody i know is like that even and i
know some like beautiful beautiful girls
i know some girls that are like so
beautiful that i just like look at them
and like oh my god i [ __ ] hate how
beautiful you are but
they also are just like oh this is like
they everybody everybody every single
woman it's like they
there's always something no matter what
they look like and i don't know why that
is it's like really bad maybe that's
just like a woman thing we're always
we always think something's wrong with
us
i don't know i certainly feel like that
and every bit every woman i know feels
like that too so
i don't know i don't know
it's i don't i don't know what to do
about it i just really don't i try to
not be like that but it's hard because
i've been like that my whole life and
i'm blessed like really i don't know how
to be a different way
grandparent says uh question for jenny
okay did you find tom's volcano level of
confidence attractive when you first met
him
um
i guess well i don't know this is like
kind of a hard question because i liked
that he was
outgoing and i liked that he seemed to
have the first thing i noticed about him
before i really knew him
because i met about ibarr uh
a long time ago tomo you tell mommy
grant there's that okay yeah we're
talking about you while you're gone
grantham's asked did you find
tom's volcano level of confidence
attractive when you first met him and i
said that's kind of a complicated
question
because
i kind of like i had seen you before i
actually met you because i had been
coming to ibarr
uh for a long time with my ex-husband
and i used to see you and i used to say
oh that guy like seems cool because you
were like a real good dresser like you
had like all the cool like goth clothes
and i said you seem to be like into all
the cool music like you like the same
music as me like
from what you dance to and stuff and i
was like oh and he's a good dancer and
he seemed to have a lot of friends and
you seemed very confident and i thought
that was cool
when i met you
i don't know i liked that but for a lot
you're gonna laugh when i say this
for a long time i thought
that
you were because a lot of your
confidence i guess is kind of like this
over the top
so i kind of it's not entirely serious
you know what i mean yeah
and so i'm joking around that's what i
mean so a lot of that was just because
you were just kind of like because you
would go over the top and just be like
to completely self-aggrandize it yeah
yeah but it was pretty obvious that you
were just like joking and you didn't
really like believe that no so because i
think for halfway for a while yeah
for a while like some people that knew
because i've lived here my whole life
but you just moved here like um
a year or two before i met you
so i think at first like a lot of people
did like you at first but a lot of
people like were put off by that they
thought that you actually like believed
yeah i did all of it all of the [ __ ]
that you said i wouldn't have cared and
that and they so they thought you were
an [ __ ] yeah and i get that like i
see where they were coming from but i
was like yeah but he's not serious
though like he doesn't actually like
believe all this like stupid [ __ ] that
he says he's just like being funny yeah
um and i think a lot of people maybe
didn't get that but a lot of people did
get that because you did have a lot of
friends and stuff
so
i don't know i guess in some ways it was
it was but i think what attracted me to
you at first
was
you seemed like real into like i liked
your style like i liked like all the
the [ __ ] that you wore i liked like the
the fact that you knew all the [ __ ]
about the music like you seemed really
into
the scene and you were like a good
dancer and like you kind of knew
everybody and i thought that was kind of
cool
like so
i don't know so i don't know i didn't
really know about like the confidence
thing until like later like after i had
met you
but
but i immediately like thought
he's kidding right like he's kidding
yeah and i was pretty sure you were but
some people didn't know that you were so
they thought oh my god what an [ __ ]
that guy is where are those people now
though that's true probably long gone
because everybody that
all my friends from back then are still
in the scene
and a lot of people who a lot of people
who are not my friends are new to the
scene so the old ones are gone
you know a lot of them i mean a lot of
the people that we know are still around
yeah like we still see them like all the
time
they're all like yeah they're all
getting old like we are yeah i have very
i have very few enemies so that's all
that yeah yeah you don't really no i
don't you don't really no um you're kind
of one of those rare people that i mean
you have a very
[Music]
on the surface it would seem that you
have like a very uh divisive personality
it's just on the surface though but yeah
that's just like surface level i mean
honestly i can't think of a single
person nowadays that doesn't like you no
because you're very good at kind of just
if they don't like me and i walk up
right up to my grab on the ass and i
start rubbing on the ass like that and
polish it make a shiny spot and then the
sun comes down and it bounces a [ __ ]
rainbow off of that ass that lands on a
bunch of shamrocks
which produce a pot of gold okay
so if you don't like me you just get a
pot of gold
gold so it's a win-win didn't they get a
gold to them and then they go away
no
it's just it's just
it was around for a long time
and over the time over time
it was politics
over time
i knew who was good and who was bad
okay
with the exception of minnie me
oh god minnie me was good at first he
went bad
so that wasn't so much like a super
villain
okay but well super villain's giving him
too much
i warned everybody so that's
oh my god
hugo says hi everybody love your wig
thank you
uh
another important thing about it
was uh
being in with
people that ended up becoming important
later on and buying their own clubs
because you have to make
you have to understand
the difference between real friends and
fake friends
okay
and big tom i knew he was a good a good
man
he offered me a bunch of money and i
said no
because i didn't need it
and my status increased in his eyes
and then later on i said i didn't turn
the money down
um out of spite or anything like that
turn the money down because we're
friends
you know man and
you don't take money from friends you
can't buy me if i'm gonna help you it's
not money's not gonna be involved and we
did help him and we did happen and then
and he owns the club that we go to now
mannequins a mannequin and he's part
owner of the new one that him and uh
scotty are right and he's asked me to be
business partners with him even though i
don't really have enough to [ __ ]
invest with him
but i would think that i'm almost
[ __ ] him if i do that
you know what i mean because
and i've told him i said look you need
to stop relying on people that you know
from the scene and stop relying on go
for professionals they will help you
more than me people that do this for a
living
and he's now doing that he's gotten rid
of all his old staff which he was
related to he's got new staff that are
professionals well he didn't fire him
they just moved to like another they
moved to another one he had yeah but
that the the rent the bar ran better if
you ask me
they mean they were
his family's good but
he needs to be away from them
he needs to send them out like scouts
to open up new territories i mean
territories that he has already
conquered he needs to have professionals
he's doing amazingly well very well like
way better than i thought he was gonna
do good but like he's doing way better
than i thought he would yeah big tom and
big tom big tom is i'd say what there's
more than one tom there's a bunch of
tops
there's me there's tom cruise and big
tom
so
that's not a bunch that's just three
it's a bunch of tops okay so we're
acting like tom cruise
yeah some people get confused i'm
talking about tom they don't realize i'm
talking about tom cruise sometimes i say
tom i'm talking about big time or
something to say tom i'm talking about
myself i don't think i ever talk to
myself in third person do i
i don't think so the evil ones talk to
me and tell me they're gonna kill me
yeah but you don't you don't use it i
never talked to myself
so um but tom
tom uh and [ __ ] armpit licker who's
another friend of ours and
i'm gonna call him armpit licker armpit
licker scott
he will lick an armpit in a [ __ ]
heartbeat he's got this armpit fetish
wait scott does that scott you didn't
know that
yeah scott will try to lick i thought
you were talking about um i thought you
were talking about our veterinarian
friend no
oh he's nipple tweaker yeah that's
nipple sugar
scott
he's never licked my armpit
you're not a teenager he's gonna try
that straight he's gonna try to grab a
teenage girl and [ __ ] lick her armpit
he's got this weird [ __ ] thing going
on
and i finally got that guy on hrt he's
lost a little bit of weight he thanked
me he says man [ __ ] yeah i'm on
[ __ ] t now i feel a lot better one of
the best things about scotty is that he
is really really into my fiction yeah he
has read
all my books and all my short stories
and he remembers all of them so like he
talks to me about them like every time i
see him and i'm just like yeah that's
okay scott's good scott's a good dude
he's a trip though he's a little weird
with you with the teenager he's got a
girlfriend yeah well like a fiance
they're engaged right yeah they don't
think they care that's his that her
she's his age yeah that's all open
though i think i think it might be yeah
i mean i hope so yeah and our scene
there's a lot of weird stuff to happen
okay yeah we don't we don't pry yeah
and uh we're curious but we don't
practice yeah
so um
scott and tom are taking over downtown
sanford
yeah they're taking it over
they try to get me to take and the cops
are involved too [ __ ] cops know him
we were looking at this other place
where he was building the new [ __ ]
the the new [ __ ] guy just posted
pictures of it today yeah it looks nice
and the cops show up
it was [ __ ] funny you know what i
mean that's like a high-end like martini
[ __ ] big tops like this is
they're doing his theme i don't know if
they're still doing this but like i did
a poster for it a while back
um the theme they're doing i don't know
if they're still doing this but they
were doing was that like old-school like
robber baron
like 20s
gilded age yeah like great gatsby that
they were doing that kind of like theme
so it's like a high-end like martini
yeah earlier on in the show a friend of
ours said i'm going to v13 that's where
he's going he's going to talk he's going
to mannequins going to mannequins at
times david parker that's he's he's a
friend of ours
i've known him for ever [ __ ] man he
helps me move yeah
i still remember that when i first moved
to like my apartment over there on aloma
yeah he helped me move
mannequins took me to took me to
7-eleven bought me some coffee and like
helped me move like help me like uh load
up the truck mannequins has a good
facebook page it's in downtown
stafford's it's called m-a-n-i-k-i-n-s
mannequins and it's got sex dolls on the
inside of it and it's like a little
[ __ ] it's kind of horror themed
horror themed [ __ ] club jenny did all
the graphics on the inside of it you can
see all the posters and stuff in there i
did those yeah we helped him open it up
we had the haitians in there [ __ ]
making the bars and [ __ ] [ __ ]
big tom's mom [ __ ] loves me okay she
works at the door she's right i love her
she's [ __ ] and she's she likes
muscular men and i every time i show up
i got to go up there and do a [ __ ]
muscle dance and [ __ ] and she's going
and then she's like don't let your old
lady see don't you
give me santa right beside she gonna get
jealous so no she's not gonna be jealous
i'm rubbing and [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
big time smiling so tom's mom yeah tom's
mom's 70 something years old you know
she works the door she's every time we
go to mannequin she's sitting right
outside the door like collecting i'm
gonna show them i'm gonna show him big
time
it's a good place it's like i honestly
he really made like i said i knew he was
gonna be successful i knew it we met him
and his wife
at ibarr
god
forever ago oh man a long time ago and
they were bringing their kids like they
had you know their kids that were like
grown and they would bring them to the
club and we'd come and dance to 80's new
wave it was a whole thing and he for a
long time he's like man i want to open
my own place it's like you guys need to
be involved and it's like he wanted to
do it for so long and then when he
finally did it i was like you know i
think that he's really going to be
successful at it but he is like [ __ ]
blowing the [ __ ] out of the water yeah
there's mannequins there's the club i
mean along that back wall you did all
that [ __ ] yeah you go in there sometimes
and the place is [ __ ] packed it's
packed all right
it's the only place like that in
downtown sanford there's really no other
that's big time
he's big he's like six two
and he saw me getting huge and he's like
going man i gotta [ __ ] so then all of
a sudden he's trying to lift he's
competing with me
that's a that's a good picture that's a
good picture you can actually like yeah
and and that's out in front of
mannequins yeah let's see what you see
is because man he'd been going to like
[ __ ] eye bar forever we've known him
forever because he loves 80s music he
loves new wave he's a huge morrissey fan
yeah he loves the smiths he loves all
that [ __ ] and he that him and his wife
would just go there and dance like every
single week they were there you're
trying to get a picture of him and for a
long time he's like i want to open my
own club i want to open myself like he'd
been wanting to do that for years and
years so he finally did it
and that's like that's so awesome and
it's like and it's making a [ __ ] ton of
money i mean it's doing really well
because like i said there's no place
downtown sanford is actually it's tiny
but it's pretty cool it's a pretty cool
place that's it on goth night actually
yes they do like gotham friday night
yeah tonight that's they call it black
friday so they usually yeah i don't know
what they call it nowadays
trying to see if we can get it but yeah
and it
they do kind of they do other stuff too
they have a drag night um
they have
karaoke i think they do karaoke on
wednesday night i think dragnet is
thursday
i can't remember what like what the
other nights are they have like other
things that they do
we've been on the karaoke night before i
haven't been on the drag night but it's
like i've done the posters for that too
but that seems fun there's a bunch of
friend of ours
oh yeah there's william in the back
angel i forgot what's his name that
black guy's name in the front what's his
name again he's [ __ ] been around for
[ __ ] that's lee lee that's right lee
he's the one lee is hilarious
lee perennis lee parents that's right
he's always he goes to he had been going
to eye bar i met him like so long yeah
the funny thing about lee is that he
always come he always came to eye bar he
always looked like [ __ ] sharp as [ __ ]
he always felt like a suits and [ __ ] he
always had like a suit and everything
like that but he would drink so much
like he'd have so many shops yeah you
could barely he kept
losing his car yeah yeah and that was
like the show where his car was
the joke was that he would always
lose his car like at the end of the
night and then like the next he'd have
to take like an uber home or a cab or
something and then like the next day he
would have to like call around and be
like where's my car yeah
it's even like lose his car or his shoes
yeah he lost his shoes
that's when it really got me with the
shoes but he lost his car like more than
once yeah and it's like it was so so
funny he was just like it's so it became
like a thing
like he would leave like at the end of
the night do you know where your car is
do you have your shoes on okay that's
like everywhere the show i'm a show on
the show uh mannequins
they're facebook
so they can know where it is all right i
gotta run and pee
so workflow okay right here
all right on facebook
it's this
the mannequin lounge
that's the club we're talking about
look
i don't know if jenny made this jenny
may have made that i don't know but
that's the
hold on got to back up
that's that dude that was married the
doll
as a club flyer
okay
i'm trying to find you some other
uh
more stuff from mannequin
sometimes he's got videos up there
girls dancing on the poles
oh here's a video
yeah it's a fun club
so if you're ever in orlando
in the orlando area
just come up north a little bit by about
10-15 miles right off of i-4
and uh
go to sanford
and check out mannequin
get out of captain kirk's chair yeah
okay
i'm just [ __ ] with india
i'm more spock than captain kirk
but i still got my own chair
did you find like good pictures of this
yeah yeah i had totally forgotten oh i
promised them pictures of the girls on
the on the pole
the girls on the pole yeah
yeah they put in a stripper pole they
got a stripper pole there wait do we
know them no no i was gonna say it's
just some from some fetish thing there
was tom right there
so that's it yeah i can't tell that you
know who that is no
i can't really see all that good okay
we're gonna do they're having a whole
thing um
memorial day weekend
which is when like the end of this month
friday night
dimitri is spinning on the patio
obviously paul vane is spinning inside
because he always does
uh then saturday they're kind of having
a thing and then sunday dimitri is
spinning at
barbarella
so we're probably going to have to go to
that god i'm just like going so broke
going all this stuff but still
who likes to dance more tom or jenny me
me
i don't think there's any kind of like
you like to dance but depends on a song
well for me it depends on the song too
although i will say that once i get real
drunk i'll just be like [ __ ] it whatever
i don't care what it is murder hornets
are talking about what up what's up with
the [ __ ] cannon and the ocp shirts
dude i know i have a maid i do they're
made with send them out look
send them
out good days and today friday friday
next week
send the order out to um the print shop
print i'll pick them up tomorrow okay
if you can send them out tomorrow i'll
pick them up tomorrow when will they be
they don't usually take that long
usually an hour or two an hour so i'll
pick them up i'll get on the bike and
i'll [ __ ] take my backpack i'll
[ __ ] ride down there i mean i don't
know like i said i don't know if there's
a closer print shop but
i'll maybe just
i'll just send it back to the send them
back to the old one i'll ride up there
on my bike and have a bike ride i'll go
pick it up i'll bring them back here and
then i'll start making the screens
because i want i need new shirts yeah
because like i said the [ __ ] all the
all the designs are done i just haven't
i just haven't sent them out for because
we have to send him to the print shop to
get the yeah uh what do you call him the
the [ __ ] on like the clear plastic so we
can shoot the screens the grapplers i
went to high school with him like i said
he's an ex cop friend of mine he says
just for your information thomas had the
exact same persona when he was 17. i
believe it a testament to his core
personality that never changed yeah it
was born that way bro
it's genetics it had to be i mean i'm
not really any different than when i was
a manager i don't think i was just like
this forever some things have changed
but not really yeah not really i think
i'm pretty much i kind of feel like most
people
yeah
you pretty much got your like core
persona by the time you're in your teens
or 20s and i don't think it changes much
after that i'm not saying it can't but
i don't really i don't really think i'm
all that different than i was when i was
younger
you know i was pretty um
i don't know i i kind of feel like i got
a pretty strong like sense of myself
when i was a kid and i didn't really
deviate that far from it you know what i
mean it's like yeah i'm a [ __ ]
uh you know
i'm like 11 12 years old i'm like well
i'm a [ __ ] weirdo that likes
horror and
is a big
atheist and i was like
i don't know it was like it was a lot of
stuff i decided on when i was like
younger that people thought i would
outgrow and i never did like the fact
that i never wanted kids
my mom kept saying oh you'll change your
mind when you get older i never did i
never did so
you know i kind of feel like most
people's core personalities established
uh but yeah when we're going back to
like who likes to dance more
i don't know the thing is once i get
started
um
and i'm pretty picky about songs
but
the drunker i get the less discerning i
get but i'm still kind of discerning you
know what i'm saying
but
i don't know sometimes tom will be like
he kind of like will dance but then
he'll like get worn out where it's like
me i'll just kind of like i'll dance for
like hours and hours like i'll dance for
like [ __ ] songs and songs and songs
and like not stop
and i'll just like get [ __ ] i'll just
get really really into it
i'll just go off into another dimension
that's my thing
and i feel like he doesn't really do
that but he's a good dancer though he's
a good dancer though he's got like
rhythm but
we always kind of laugh i'm just like i
don't mean like cast aspersions on
people but
when we were at mannequins last saturday
and remember
we talked about it
what did we talk about it i think we
talked about it on like um last sunday's
show we talked about we went to
mannequins on
saturday night now friday night is more
they're like goth industrial night
saturday nights is more kind of like a
wild card situation where it's like they
start out with like 80s new wave they
play a lot of stuff like that like last
week we went eight uh last saturday and
like early in the evening they played
like sisters of mercy they played the
fall
they played like some [ __ ] like that um
but then like as the night went on they
started playing like kind of [ __ ] like
what did they start playing that was
that started to annoy me i don't
remember what it was but they started
going like more 90s and they started
going like pop punk and they started
doing like [ __ ] like that and they
started like playing hip-hop and they
started playing stuff like that and i
was just kind of like hey man whatever
but
i kind of feel like
i don't know so
so i don't know i got into that
but
i don't know i don't even remember where
i was going with that where was i going
with that i don't know
i don't want to go i don't know
grantham says i would wear the [ __ ] out
of a tyrell corporation shirt how do i
get one
well uh once i go down and pick up the
[ __ ] thing well we have the tyrell
corporation shirt we have a screen for
that yeah i have that i have that so all
you got to do is like send a super chat
yeah or if you can contact me we no look
we uh we we have a personal connection
on facebook
uh on on messenger send me what size you
want
okay yeah cause we haven't sometimes i
might need to like order some blank
shirts because i don't know we have some
shirts but i don't know like what size
yeah uh i don't know if you've seen it
it's a round disc and it says tyrell
corporation more human than human
[ __ ] genetic replicants it's good
i've worn it on the show
i got a bunch of different shirts we can
put it on hit me up on a messenger and
i'll uh give you jenny's um
[ __ ] paypal and send her the money
and i'll send you the shirt and we need
yeah we need like your home address
our p.o box or whatever so we can like
it's gonna be about 20 bucks yeah like
we just need to know like what size
right so in case i need to order one we
do have some blank shirts in stock yeah
but i haven't looked for a while so i
don't know like we don't know what size
i don't know what sizes i got in there i
usually like order like
a couple hundred dollars worth of yeah
blank shirts every now and then if you
guys have if you guys haven't never seen
the uh more human than human shirt i'll
bring one out
okay just to show it to you yeah you got
one because i got a bunch of them i wear
them all the time
grandpa these shirts are actually i make
them for myself
jenny made this one this is our friend's
face well we made i made this yeah yeah
we make all our own [ __ ]
we made this one too
i mean i have a zazzle store too which
like different designs on it but the
ones that we do that are just kind of
like
white on black we just we do those
it's painted ass but i don't mind it's a
lot cheaper than zazzle is
you know
i wish i could remember what i was
talking about before but i can't
[Laughter]
i can't
somebody said uh sergeant has 64. i
don't know i don't know what that means
i don't know what that means
okay yeah there's this is the more human
than human shirt yeah that's it and it's
got the little yeah 13 o'clock logo on
the back and on the back
13 o'clock
so it has two images
it's a good shirt i wear that's a club
looks great
yeah people seem to like that
making my hair all messy
[Music]
all right
grandpa says so cool
i wish i had time to like do more shirts
it's like i have
the ones i have ready i have an mtv like
an old school mtv one if you want to do
that i have that i have
um
a canon one
that i made so it's like it's really
crisp and oh hey trey says 10 bucks
thank you very much trey oh you're
you're he says congratulations on 300
episodes of the main show oh thank you
very much thank you thank you for the
super chat we're trying to make money
here thank you yeah
i know i can't believe we've done like
at 300 episodes yeah
grampus is all so cool yeah yeah no
that's a great shirt
that's a great shirt tammy says i'd be
more human than human with that [ __ ]
right there a genetic replica
from the tyrell corporation i told you
man if i could like pop my consciousness
into like a [ __ ] body
actually you know would be super cool
is if you have like a whole bunch of
different bodies like it hanging in your
closet like out you take them yeah and
you could just like pop your
consciousness into yeah anyone you want
probably have an event what do i want to
look like today oh i'm down i'm totally
down for that or you just live in the
metaverse
yeah that's cool too that's cool too
i know some people are weirded out by
that but i was like what are you talking
about that's an awesome idea when you
start getting too old and your body
sucks it would be a good option yeah
maybe young people but i don't know
maybe younger people would be like what
i like this by this place well it might
be a good idea to where you have young
people live a normal life and then old
people live in the metaverse
and then they live forever in the
metaverse that way you have i'm all
about it you kind of have like the same
life cycle as butterflies and [ __ ] where
they're pew pie and little larvae and
then they become a butterfly in the
[ __ ] cyber
space you know be like that
oh you live in life you know what i mean
ago
so it's not like you're not living a
life
or ending your life too soon
yeah i mean like i said that's you know
you wouldn't do it all the time it's
just kind of like [ __ ]
uh tammy says i have several of your
shirts and can attest they are comfy and
hold up to washing i mean i try to get
good [ __ ] for that stuff i get my stuff
from uh jiffy shirts
in case anybody's tammy says i have
several of your shirts i just said that
okay okay i just said it and here's it
well you need to listen murder hornet
says i can't wear the shirt with the
reaper on it to mexico looks just like
santa muerte yeah smugglers pray to that
i'll get searched yeah
trey says oh this is a good idea
actually you all should do a knockoff of
the night of the living dead shirt with
the little girl on it but with jenny
little oh yeah yeah yeah
you know the girl yeah the little
daughter with this baby oh that's a good
idea i'm gonna like i'm gonna write that
down i'm gonna write that down
that's actually a great idea
because i we had the kind of idea to do
like horror themed shirts that were like
take-offs on
trey says he has three shirts now and
they've held up very well yeah we cook
the [ __ ] out of them to make sure that
that that image stays on there
and we source good quality shirts
like i said i do try to get the good
[ __ ] from you yeah although i must say
that um
this
tank top that we got from walmart with
the little straight lines on it i like
it better
than the shirt that we got from our
service that and because of the sizing
the sizing on those is a little bigger
than it claims to be well the thing
about jiffy shirts is that they have so
many yeah options
small is more like medium with a shifty
shirt
if you ask me because we got mediums and
they're a little too big
for me
that's right yeah you really got to
watch and it depends on the shirt too it
depends on like what it's made of
because like i said i'll get stuff from
like jiffy shirts like they'll have like
one that's sort of like a bargain option
which is like a little bit
thinner or something like that but then
like you get ones that are 100 cotton
you get ones that are really so they
have like a zillion different things so
sometimes it's like hard to pick and
sometimes they're out of stuff and i
have to like get another brand and like
you know but graham i'll hit uh hit me
up or remind me on uh messenger
and i'll uh hook you up some good shirt
action to show you where to pay
that way um
that way
youtube doesn't [ __ ] steal all that
money super chats they get some of that
money not a lot it's not a lot but we'll
go around that
um murder hornet also says i still want
the btk i got sexual problems we should
do okay i'm gonna do it you can come up
with something like that that looks good
[Laughter]
i keep i just keep forgetting i wanted
to be kind of geometric and cool looking
there's no way you can work that out
where that's symmetric yeah okay
something that was good in the club
[ __ ] we'll put
btk bgk on that channel charles raider
with this super sexual problem dennis
raider dennis raider yeah not charles
yeah where's his where's his bobble head
is he back there is he back there he's
back there he doesn't have anything to
say
are you sure yeah he didn't have
anything to say i'm too drunk
that's
get dennis you know you know how
everyone loves dennis
[Laughter]
look at his little head bobbling around
you know how it is
jenny's always trying to call me out
here because she loves me you know tom
he he's the thing of the past
once i got out of prison i'm me and
jenny we're gonna run off
[Laughter]
look at him
how's he gonna compete with this
[Laughter]
isn't that right jenny
sir you know i love you
[Laughter]
i love the fact that
dennis raider he's still alive right
dennis raider is a [ __ ] guest on the
show that would be [ __ ] hilarious if
he was like watching this [ __ ] do they
let them watch youtube in prison
probably not probably not probably not
but they might have let him have they
that would be really funny if like he
watched this and he we were making fun
of it they might allow him to have cell
phones now who knows that that would
like be really funny to me yeah man
can i [ __ ] tom yeah that's what he's
like yeah
i'm like i'm sorry dennis but if one no
i'm not sorry i'd love to [ __ ] he
needs to get a wi-fi hot spot we'll look
him up we'll have him on as a guest for
the show
oh come on
that's not gonna go well i could tell
you that much right now i don't have i
don't have any
how are you doing pacers
you're looking good man you're looking
real good
how's it hanging you know that kind of
are you very upset get your old lady yet
are you very good you're up in the
prison you get you an old lady yet
you've been in prison a long time
yeah
let me send you some cigarettes
saying some cigarettes you can get your
girlfriend
yeah he's
walking down the floor i mean he's
institutionalized at this point oh yeah
he's crazy
the dumbest thing about btk
well i guess about like serial killers
in general of that milk
is that
if he would have just
shut the [ __ ] up and not sent [ __ ] to
the media he probably would have like
got away with it
he didn't he he won't he didn't want to
get away with it he just wanted it yeah
he wanted attention yeah he wanted like
he wanted to get to get credit for what
he what he got what he did
and he was mad that people were just
kind of like oh this is unsolved and
people were like
not forgetting about it necessarily but
i never got credit for what i did you
know
which is crazy that's crazy
well you're
you have to uh see it from his point of
view which means you got to flip it
around a little bit
he thought what he did was like a
[ __ ] work of art that that [ __ ] was
awesome and yeah he wanted
because these are projects he wanted
recognition he wanted recognitions like
yeah he didn't like the people i know
you guys like forgetting he's like i
know you guys don't like it and you're
taught that it's bad but
you know man's got to do what he's got
to do you know man like me has to do we
i have the x factor
yeah and it's time for nick isn't that
what he called it the x factor x factor
factor x right
yeah and he called it um
the minotaur the mandatory yeah he had a
weird thing about a minute i'm a
minotaur and i have to [ __ ] cash in
on minotaur coins
that's what he was doing
but he's kind of he's one of those
[ __ ] he's living in another
universe well yeah he's like um a more
extreme version of these [ __ ]
like you just got you guys just can't
handle my realness yeah he's one of
those kind of [ __ ] yeah except
he actually killed people yeah
yeah and i can't stand those kind of
people like i said well they got upset
you know that's what i did
and i've said this on the show like lots
of times like look obviously serial
killers are the worst they're like the
scum of the earth yeah
but
it's bad enough that they do what they
do but then some of them like btk like
dennis have to like compound the error
by being all like arrogant and smug
about it it's like oh my god i just
can't
i can't
i hate smug like i said it's
if you're a serial killer and then
you're smug on top of it [ __ ] that that
makes me really really angry that makes
me really that just makes me want to
like [ __ ] punch you right in the
[ __ ] taint yeah
everyone like stick my hand up your ass
and just pull all your [ __ ] organs
out it's just oh it makes me so mad that
makes me so mad i'm like where the [ __ ]
do you get off please stop it please
stop it that's his superpower
i guess yeah it's not a super power it's
not it's a superpower well yeah i know
in their mind in their delusional
[ __ ] minds
super power cessp says he really
shouldn't have sent that floppy disk
dumbass yeah exactly yeah and the the
most hilarious thing the thing that
makes me laugh so much about that was
that he actually asked the cops
can you guys trace me from a floppy disk
and the cops are like no of course not
and then he was mad when they said you
and then he was mad that's not honest
when they did he's like you lied to me
he's like well duh
this goes back
this is this goes back to what i was
saying before
we are a multiplicity of personalities
all happening in the subconscious
okay
uh there is skinny puppy called it right
they called they they said mind the
perpetual intercourse that's the name of
one of their albums because that's what
your mind is a [ __ ] constant
conversation
between all these different [ __ ]
factions tell me about it
yeah it's a constant conversation inside
your [ __ ] subconscious between all
these other personalities
and they come to an agreement and allow
your consciousness to have
an opinion
this isn't me saying it that's just well
documented
your subconscious mind which is a group
of
consciousnesses in your subconscious
come to a conclusion
and then send that conclusion to you
making you think it was your idea
it's some heavy [ __ ]
the mind is a lot more complicated than
people think okay
well in dennis rader
and all these serial killers
there's more than one personality in the
subconscious and they're all talking to
each other
some of them don't agree with this [ __ ]
okay of what the man consciousness is
doing
so if you ask me what happened was is
that there was a consensus inside
the unconscious
that you got to go to jail for what you
[ __ ] did okay because you know you
got to pay for this [ __ ]
so that made they made the conscious
raider believe that it was his idea to
start toying with the police again yeah
that's what so he could get caught well
a lot of times i do kind of feel like
serial killers have this weird i don't
know if i'd necessarily call it a fail
safe because it would have been nice if
they'd done that before they killed
anybody but
um a lot of them do seem like uh yeah as
it goes on they do kind of want to get
caught right because they'll start like
doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] whereas
yeah you're getting over me the other
start taunting the other facets of their
personality saying that no this is not
sustainable and you're killing people
and too many people and for the wrong
reasons and that you're the only one
that's been benefiting from this and
it's a sexual motive and you're not
benefiting and this is unjust so you got
to be punished for this so it starts
[ __ ] sending all this to them
and eventually the main consciousness of
the waking consciousness is driven to
its own capture
through that system
and
i think oh what's his name
[ __ ]
would agree with me the guy who who uh
what was that guy's name
well narrow it down the guy who [ __ ]
wrote the thing about the cosmic
unconscious and the unconsciousness uh
[ __ ]
not sigma freud carl young young it's
jungian
it's young and stuff happening
inside the subconscious
and
the more intense your waking
your waking life is
the more excitement in it the more drama
uh the more action that's in it the
stronger all those personalities become
that's in my that's in my personality i
mean the thing that kills me about
dennis yeah
is that look everybody has
different [ __ ] going on in their head
like everybody has that but just like
everything else is a spectrum it's just
like a matter of degree like i have
different voices in time and like you
should do this and you should do this
blah blah everybody has that
but i kind of feel like the thing that
[ __ ] me up the most reading that
because remember sophie sent me that
book about uh btk like conversations
with the killer or whatever it's called
the thing that killed me the most about
him was the
compartmentalization
yeah because like as
much as i have different voices in my
head like pulling me this way or that
way
i still feel like cohesive in the sense
that i still feel like one person i
still feel like hey this is like [ __ ]
up like i still they're still like bleed
over he didn't really seem to have that
because he had a wife
who he apparently would never kill he
had a daughter
and yet
he was still completely comfortable
treating other women
as though they were objects yeah but he
didn't really seem to see
that his wife and his daughter were the
same
as the other victim he didn't really
seem to see that and that like kind of
blew my mind a little bit like i get it
because
like i said everybody has that but the
compartmentalization was just like
[ __ ]
extreme i think other facets in him saw
that though
i guess that's why that's [ __ ] up
that's why that that's why they
compelled him to get caught
all that stuff about [ __ ] re-emerging
and talking to the police and oh you
can't really catch ah [ __ ] he he was
not dumb he was trying to get caught in
a certain at a certain level in his mind
he knew
i mean he might not have consciously
known that but subconsciously i think
yeah
and i think like that happens a lot
especially these serial killers that
kind of like keep taunting the police
after if honestly if some serial killers
just shut up and went into hiding they
did not have a gun they probably never
have caught them right but the fact that
they still had to keep like interacting
with they still needed that validation
and that attention
that's what got them caught but i think
in a lot of ways
that's like you said their subconscious
i don't think they're aware of it not a
conscious level but subconsciously
they wanted to get caught they want to
get caught
because obviously why would they [ __ ]
and they want the recognition for what
they did sure validation and then they
somehow want the forgiveness like
they're coming clean
uh and then they want the punishment
they want all that
and but it's all the subconscious i
think that they believe that being
punnett caught and punished for it
erases it
you know i think they do actually like
they might believe that right they might
believe it right that it's like been
expirated yeah it's like now they're
innocent again i think that's what's
happening which is crazy i mean yeah
one thing one thing that i find really
interesting and enlightening about
reading about serial killers is that
i find them interesting because to me
their
thought processes
while intellectually i understand how
they got from a to b are very alien so
in a way that kind of like makes me feel
better like when i was reading the btk
book i was like look i understand how he
got from this point to that point like i
understand how that happened
but
it's still
[ __ ] insane like it's still like i
would never have made that connection
like in my own mind so i was like good
that probably means that i'm not a
serial killer then do you know what i
mean it's just kind of like
the dude's thought process is just
[ __ ]
incomprehensible incomprehensible
well i don't want to say
incomprehensible because i comprehend it
i know how he got from one point to
another but
i don't like i intellectually understand
it but i don't relate i can't relate
because i don't think like that
so it seems crazy to me
uh cessp said he makes the ugliest woman
too
those polaroid photos are not good
yeah i mean if dennis rader
uh
was happy with those and kept him and
like thought he looked pretty i'm not
judging well i'll judge him because he's
a serial killer
but
you know maybe we can all think that we
look pretty because he
apparently like thought he looked good
and that was like he was probably
jerking off to that [ __ ]
sorry
but he probably was
what's this
is [ __ ] up he's listening to me right
now little dennis back there but the
thing about it is that we have an hh
homes also we have like another we have
a bobble head of h.h holmes who is
back there somewhere
but
we don't bring him out as much because
tom has never
he can't channel h.h holmes no he's but
he's long gone we don't really know what
his voice sounded like right so
no i can't channel him we never brought
him out as much talking about his murder
hotel he's too far gone in the past he's
too long gone i don't know i kind of
feel like if you like
communed with him long enough you could
like maybe get into like a little bit of
it i have a feeling that he talked a bit
like this
he probably something like that yeah
yeah
something uptight like he's very
intelligent
something like that
i think
if you inhale this gas you'll be fine it
will get rid of any of your problems
here climb inside the box
then i'll just put you down this shield
and then all like
boil all your flesh off and sell your
skeleton to medical science that's how
that works
murder heart is trying to get me to do
trent
i'm not gonna do trend man
tran
makes you evil you know uh too many bad
side effects
if i did anything new that i haven't
done before it'd be like echo pose echo
pose would be the [ __ ] horse
testosterone wouldn't mind doing that
but at least i don't know if i can get
it though i'll go ahead
murder hornet also says jail is nice
sleep all day yeah
yeah
i don't think i could sleep all day yeah
even if i was in jail how long have you
been streaming
three hours 12 minutes this is about
time you realize that three hours is
normally the cut off unless you guys
have anything important you want us to
talk about
where uh
if you don't guys have any good good
suggestions you don't drop them in the
in the uh
chat there me and jenny will check off
here in a bit
three hours is a long time and the
storm's coming anyway
aren't you hungry
a little bit okay i got all kinds of
stuff down there what you got
man i got well you don't like [ __ ] um
i had a bunch of rice that i was going
to throw out i turned it into rice
pudding it's great indian rice pudding
i'm not a fan okay i have rice pudding
um i have
hamburgers
i got some thawed hamburger already
that sounds good yeah you want a
hamburger okay yeah hamburger tomatoes
lots of pickles yeah i got [ __ ]
tomatoes pickles got everything they got
buns and new buns it's the small buns
though from my puppy that's okay okay i
mean you know all right
so there's buns and lots of pickles and
tomatoes on it i'm good yeah i guess
everything is okay
everything's ready all right we'll see
then we'll see him later
yeah okay shut it down sergeant dead
head said good y'all i gotta go
yeah gotta go more beer please be here
when i get back
we're going to be here when you get back
no we're not going to be here
i mean you know it's been a while
i would like to hang out but i am like
kind of hungry yeah hungry we've been on
for three hours yeah it'll be all right
we'll be back on sunday
uh oh murder hornet's trying to ask
another question what do you say how
prepared are the north korean army
uh
okay the north korean army is [ __ ] a
pretty good anti-invasion army
what makes them so good is it is that
they're intensely undermined there's
tunnels everywhere
they have commando units that have
[ __ ] they can spray out poison gas
they all got all kinds of weird [ __ ]
um the thing is though is that the north
koreans are only good in the first
couple of days
after two or three days they're gonna
start petering out
and uh they they are totally
focused just on the korean peninsula
they can't project outside that and it's
more like one huge suicide attack
could they actually uh invade the south
yeah they could they have those
submarines and everything
could they get on on on on the southern
land and do a lot of damage yeah they
could
could they actually take over the south
and claim it for their own no they
couldn't
they could they're all the only thing
about them is that they can threaten to
do a lot of damage to the south that's
all they that's all that and that's how
they survive
their whole thing is imagine it's a guy
in a box he can't get out but he's got a
pistol
all right and then he's got a little
hole in the side of the [ __ ] box and
he says if you [ __ ] with me i'm gonna
shoot her and that's all he does
that's all he does he can't come really
come out of the box
he can't really [ __ ] get that woman
he can't really do anything
that's that that's that's north korea
for you
but i don't think that's a good analogy
that's what they do
but i don't disrespect north korea they
have unlimited endurance and willpower
they're tough little [ __ ]
at the top okay
and but it totally [ __ ] up
totalitarian society it's like something
out of 1984 it's worse
worse than the soviet union worst and
worse than
[ __ ]
mustache man and the germans of the back
bent cross much worse than that they're
bad very very bad
totally inhuman to their own people
uh but i i respect their strength
when they're and they just
it's like a dude that you shoved into a
box decades ago and you still won't
surrender
that's what that's what you're dealing
with
they're nuts they're nuts there's
nothing like that well that probably
helps yeah
there's nothing like this being
completely enough they're nuts yeah sure
yeah i think okay that's all i'm gonna
say
[Laughter]
all right
yeah it's ooh it's starting to storm
outside uh so yeah we're gonna go and
get something to eat
we'll be back on sunday talking about
some movie we don't know what yet but
it'll be something entertaining i'm sure
so thanks everybody for dropping by
hanging out with us this friday night
thanks for all your super chats and we
will see you guys on
sunday evening bye